[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
yes sir yes sir
the lord dave what's going on people
talk to me how my levels are sounding
shout out to gerald mack up in the realm
very early salute to him you already
know a cute perspective was going on two
man 55 was going on lord metroid what's
going on it's gonna be interesting game
of the year discussion
yeah
yeah we're gonna talk about it i know
saul probably gonna talk about it that
was his topic we pushed it back a week
you know what i'm saying we had a little
jason ronald so we want to buckle down
with other stuff
jeremy brown what's going on talking top
of the morning time good morning to you
lord xcoin i see you let's go that's
right we got the legendary snow bike
mike
[Music]
yeah jeffy says always wrong myself
anyway it's gonna be lit we're waiting
for other lords to get in here we got
snowbike mike in a building it's gonna
be a fun one a lot of fun discussion
crown your lord returns that's where the
lords we go through the game award
nominees we make our picks and then uh
we watch the show and see who got the
answers right who got the most winners
who votes it up so i've usually dominate
so i know jeremy brown said sava's wrong
but uh he'd be uh he'd be right a lot oh
okay you say it cause king oh okay hey
lois
listen we gonna see what's going on we
need therapy what's going on
ksit what up bro what's going on happy
sunday top of the morning
but yeah man we gotta have some fun i'm
waiting for other lords to get in here
attic probably in the bushes i spoke to
king earlier and then uh saul will be
pulling up but we got some legendary
snowflake mike pulling up in a few it's
gonna be turned up we're gonna have some
fun derek summer what's up we had to
start for a new destiny player lore wise
just so much hit up my boy ibantis
youtube channel hit up he bounced his
youtube channel
he's great for new destiny players and
um
if you want lore of course you gotta go
to the lower meister i would say you got
to go to my name is bife as a byf and i
would say
milan games
nye llim games he's great um so many man
like i can't even begin but those would
probably be my first stars if you really
want to get into the lore and all that
but
look we will be back i'm going to try to
get snow bike in here and meet my mic
before king messes up our monetization
with his music yeah yeah i play [ __ ]
over here but he got to redo that he got
to redo that because one he didn't tell
me he was gonna do shinobi
that day because i wouldn't be in the
stream the whole time the second he had
it way too hard not on arcade levels
like the um emulation one was doing too
much so we're gonna give him a pass on
that one he gonna rematch it the right
way because we gotta see what he can do
so anyway i'll see y'all in a minute
y'all
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal i got
it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest and starter regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is
but i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'd be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddy and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they're really mechanical and yeah
i be eating these rappers but that's all
a part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is the yoga
[Music]
boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
which lies
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young woofer
then they would mistake me for addict if
i can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny word to kinda who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really be
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
[Music]
and we are live
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on lordsagaming.net
episode number 235. then it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm extremely
excited about our special guest and
we've got halo infinite multiplayer
progression
the fracture tenri event
game award nominations and crown your
lord returns so we gonna get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who not only
has one of the most recognizable and
passionate voices within our gaming
community but easily matches it with a
tremendous work ethic positive vibes and
outstanding content creation
introducing the creator of the snow bike
bike twitch and youtube channels
professional shoutcaster plus the host
of the kinda funny x-cast
my fellow lord of fitness games
prog pug dad to the splash sisters who
reminds gamers always to get hype and
stay
active live from cali and kind enough to
make his debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord snow bike mike how you doing
sir
i hit the lights i should be coming out
to a big intro right now
you know what good morning everybody
it's the lord's day it's sunday and i
get to spend it right here in the realm
i'm pretty pumped up i'm feeling good
looking good i appreciate the kind words
always lord cognito and uh i'm really
excited to be next to these three
because they know i'm big fans of all of
them and i know my guy king david and i
about to get really loud on that i
already know you two together a fun time
but i'm really excited thank you so much
for having me on no
still want you a little louder they said
might come in a little low so maybe you
could turn your back up just leave a
little bit more they want more money
yeah i appreciate it
no doubt yeah man good to have you a
lord in your round man absolute pleasure
to have you long overdue
what have you been playing sir what have
you been playing
you know what lord i've been playing a
lot uh when i look back on it it's been
a fun time right finished up all the
races in forza horizon 5. so been
speeding around mexico which has been a
blast even doing it on the x-cloud of
course over on my phone in bed which has
been a blast
last magnificent oh it's incredible
right oh my gosh it's really really good
i don't even speak on it i played halo
infinite multiplayer last night on my
phone and it ran very well i was very
impressed with it so shout out to xcloud
for always racing the game but when i
look back on it i've been playing
gladius thanks to backwards
compatibility i jump back on that old
joint nice i'll tell you what men to
make those games look good for being
like you know 18 plus years old that
game still looks good yeah you messed by
that having a good time
loving psychonauts too i jumped into
skyrim to jump back okay uncle todd you
know i'm mike howard song
okay okay
he makes nothing but bangers and i'm
pretty excited about star field next
year so i jumped in the skyrim
celebrating ten years and
loving that really feeling just the vibe
of that i know y'all in trouble today
rock
don't say that snow bike man because i i
say i'm excited for starfield i get but
we don't know nothing about it
ain't nobody gonna talk about that
a little bit higher so just on my side
too see if that could compensate
i'm playing around with mine on my side
so we'll keep messing with we'll keep
messing with it until we get it alex i
want you to get hyped all the time if
something excites you something
energizes you you'll share the passion
oh so you can see you share the passion
yeah see snowbike ain't nobody gonna
bully me on this show
so the chat i think they're gonna bully
me into something else they got
something else coming
y'all are ridiculous i'll be high i'll
be hyped to to play with a rock outside
before these people tell me i can't be
all ridiculous anyway got a lot of show
to get into we go you already know we
got the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with a little bit not too
much time sensitive intro king king king
anyway
welcome
back to the co-host my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh
kind of what could say i just woke up 15
minutes ago but you know it's uh
i'm
pretty wide awake right now you know uh
i actually been playing i went back and
i started playing halo reach again
because it's been so long since i played
that and like seeing like the spartans
like talking to each other like you
really get a good sense like the these
spartans knew what was up like they knew
they weren't living that like like and
it gives you like
three four like even bungie back in the
day they kind of started going down that
hill on giving spartans like the human
side of them we're like
like they can die because we we see
master chief so much and where he it
feels like he's invincible he never has
any type of like error where he can get
where he can get uh defeated like what i
really like is like that game show that
spartans can easily die
the vulnerability it's just it's just
they made us play as the one that never
dies
so but uh you know definitely uh
having a having a good pretty good week
you guys i definitely like having snow
bike mike i'm gonna have to keep saying
snow bikes so bike snow bikes
i got to do it too he's practicing
so
it's it's gonna be a good show man we
got these uh game award nominations so
yeah i don't know it says since you're
going to be here the whole show snow
snow bike
how we do these nominations is is is we
do a tally yeah and whoever has the most
uh uh when the actual awards happen is
the is the lord that wins after
the video game awards normally we
normally we
we never have like another person doing
this it's going to be interesting having
yeah because then we could tally up
mike's responses right again
you're not going to regain anything and
cog is trying to put us under the road i
try to have revision
like last year when they were like oh
it's a tie between you and king what do
you guys want me give me king just like
almost at the exact same time what i is
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patreon of
the iron bank my man lord sovereign how
are we doing sir i'm doing pretty good
i'm you know on in the bush it's just
like attic i just woke up oh i knew
something was up i came through the back
door
i hope everybody had a good holiday ate
a lot spent too much money which i did
yeah
black friday says this is lit yeah man
so um yeah what have i played uh not too
much i actually got a chance to play a
little bit of halo multiplayer this is
the funny thing in my house right
i played a little bit yesterday morning
because the thing is
ladies
gotta love ladies out the lady song lady
saab does not understand online
etiquette there is nothing
hey standing in front of the tv no
no no no and i was like
yo you kill so i can't honestly if i sat
down to play a game with you guys y'all
cursed me out straight up straight that
would curse me out because it would be
like all right hold on a second all
right i'm gonna leave this game and come
back yeah you didn't do that
i got a taste of that progression oh
we'll talk about it oh my lord oh yeah
don't bother the beta
oh
did you
justin timberlake is back baby
he's now a founding member he's returned
like finally got the the kd ratio a
little better than it had been because
you haven't haven't played halon quite
some time did you go to that bot train
and then go
actual human beings now but it was it
was rough in the beginning it was like
oh yeah mike mike what was that was you
drinking from what was that great
chalice that you pulled up yeah that's a
beast nice little water bottle right now
this thing is the joint right here oh
yeah this is the joint right here
nice i'm loving all your swags yeah
that's a very royal fast bike
i'm sitting there pulling up the whole
workout cup
let me get the xbox chain
i don't watch a video though i'm always
listening to the podcast but not oh you
do the audio okay that's what you're
doing yeah yeah what happens see what
happens when you just do audio
you know that um i'll be playing some
gta uh trilogy
that that that one patch that they've
dropped so far has done wonders for that
yeah wow that's what's up that's what
yeah
for the horizon as well just jumping in
doing some races running around the
world getting some barn finds um man man
besides that halo reach i have not
played any other game besides halo
infinite wow
i could probably put three to five hours
a day
i get it yeah when i i said let me see
if it has that old feel like one more
one more one and it it really like every
single i feel you let's say
okay
you know it's an experience man playing
that game with kids smooth oh you shot
the kids
we got megatron in this chat i want to
shout out him i want to shout out lock
remember attic we had the big party with
them 12 player
big t battle people coming in and out i
used to i i used to not like big team
battle at all i know i love big teams
well i think i think it's because i only
whatever went in there are four people
but like i only like playing big team
battle when at least
eight
yeah it's on your squad as opposed to
the years blueberries no doubt because
because if you don't know 12 and the
majority if it's the other team i'm
spending the majority of the time
complaining about them and not playing
the game i can't you're ridiculous
anyway and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
b
love it lord keg how are we doing sir
man i got snow bike mike over here the
king of bling he's definitely doing it
up oh man i could not wait for today you
have no idea
oh he's coming it's coming with the ice
might feel like uh run the jewels yes
yes that's that's what we feel like the
jewels y'all in trouble today
y'all in trouble today
not more trouble than teal fimo lopez
when he was watching the fight i said
anytime a boy come up with excuse before
the fight he's not looking good
you know he was he was he was trying to
duck this fade for eight months and the
fade caught him he caught him and he
came out crazy in the first round tell
female lopez came out swinging he was
bombarded and boom boom and wifey in the
background like oh baby ah i'm down for
10 feet
and then
rc from down under here with the unknown
and he looked up like oh that's not
supposed to happen wow
speaking of not looking good did y'all
see the frank mayor
um
versus the boxer on triller and they
they they doing a mortal kombat mean
when you know your man get knocked out
and stand in place and he's doing this
yes frank man was literally finishing go
it was a boxing match it was a boxing
match bro why would frank mayer do this
you know how the mma dudes they never
seen that type of check but anyway
yeah he needed to check anyway
12 rounds went by yeah
uh and you know my wife was like no i
think he won baby i said no he did not
win
i said and this is a simple way that you
can know who won the fight when you look
at the guy and say
two guys both of them yeah who would you
rather be
would you rather would you rather be who
would you rather be this dude literally
look like he did not have on a seat belt
and then you took an air bag
debbie look yes so
oh man he lost all his belts but that's
what happened when you rest on your
loyals and you talk too much and you
don't do what you're supposed to do no
doubt what you've been playing sir
oh
oh i got to say i got to say whoa
shout out to game pass and phil
dominance maximus aurelius spencer
oh what phil diamond
what's going on single-handedly
but he did it me christmas wow
no christmas for you no christmas for
you who did he say no christmas for you
he did he did lump a cold if you ain't
getting out his get down and lay down
the game pass is crazy right now like
game passes literally xbox dudes are
shopping for refrigerators shout out to
everybody
[Laughter]
salute the lemon one away dragon all of
everybody yes yes
first of all i want to say happy
birthday a big happy birthday shout out
to my man hip hop gamer oh salute
god bless you
bring so much to this space happy
birthday happy birthday it was yesterday
oh i didn't even
shout the king out good yes yes
um mortal shell i've always wanted to
play it okay right so i saw fax clown
and i jumped in
did not like what i see oh
no no
i'm not a more or um like there's the
soul's typing
yeah you don't like you yeah that's all
that's good
wave yeah
and i i saw it i looked at it and i said
i love this x cloud i did not have to
dirty my uh ssd
salute to that it's the wrong game to
play that with yeah
you got to download that one
check it out that's a super tribe before
you buy like you you literally don't
have to mess your ssd up with no space
no information
that that game gonna mess you up and
file
i don't know
it's gone that was it but respect for
being able to try it right with with the
with the cloud streaming and having that
ability without like you said taking up
hard drive space it's a cool feature for
sure i went to back to scarlet nexus i
was playing my uh fuzz horizon uh you
know on five shout out to the christmas
uh packages
and then
my beta boy got in full swing
yo you wanna know how much of a beatable
i am what you're doing i picked up the
ultimate season package oh you didn't
see it
[Laughter]
literally you are ashy and you
definitely need some lotion because
oh god and then
you got that gray suit on
it looks like they dipped you in
someone's ashes
i guess like when it comes to stuff i've
never cared about cosmetics
like most of the time dude like they'll
be like oh why why why you why are you
looking like that because i could change
the color i don't want to i don't want
to light up in a room
someone walks into a room and they only
see one white gray blue spartan they're
gonna shoot me first
so listen uh-huh 44 dollars was well's
the worst
salute to you you support the dab sir
you're supposed to yeah that's right i
don't care about that
you know what i care about me looking
good okay
so check it out yes the the best thing
about this package is they got a button
that says um level boost oh
no
with you that is your hand oh god so
level boost is crazy right so i was
level one i hit level i hit level boost
it said level 30. yeah wow
that is so king like that that literally
feeds into your yeah that is that is
like that that's an immediate
almost 50. we was all in the same room
we all just started the game together
and then
they said how the hell you know
and with the plaques
oh you got to get your wallet out this
is this is the one that's where the
millions kicked in that's where the
millions kicked in
i can't wait to talk about this topic i
don't know that's what i've been playing
um and then i went back to play like i
said a little bit of scarlet nexus i
think that game is very underrated but
there's so much stuff that i'm i'm
trying to jump back into games that i
haven't even got a chance to play yet i
feel you bro and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi lord
cognito spread that realism around the
iop not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to hear shout out to
the ladies to find the duke my boy
maddie plays we had a great time talking
about halo what's going on with sega saw
so you you like that uh conversation so
oh i know i've heard that conversation
thank you
i know you you would appreciate that
exactly
a man with some sense thank you
sounds like somebody's going at me but
uh how i see it is uh
he's bending the knee to me soon we'll
see where
i'll i'll buy you some new sunglasses
okay well make sure they hunt it like
this
so yeah we definitely talk more about
that uh sega microsoft relationship also
shout out to the lsn patreon we had a
defining ultimate exclusive with the
legendary chris ray gun really getting
into the nitty-gritty of that
multiplayer the game play the field all
that so check that out that'll be out no
last word this week when he bought his
truck ty got travis hello you know
thanksgiving break kind of chill you
know what i'm saying we'll be back next
week with all that destiny talk that
y'all want for me yeah halo infinite all
day kind of like what addict said been
rocking that and guardians of the galaxy
been really getting my guardians on so
much fun that game is really really
impressing me each way different than
avengers right oh my god it's night and
day shout out to idols they doing it and
shout the king man the king the homie
came through for me it was looking
spooky for me on that mini fridge it was
like 108 hit me i'm like damn the kid
got me okay call he's like yo come
through right now your boy got his bitty
fridge lit it up hit the button did you
turn your joint on kick you turn your
chin
your mind is sitting in the box you know
the flex is on the flex got it and you
don't have to open it up right now
when i wanna no i will say it's really
quick a little loud you got a little
noisy but other than that real real cool
yeah you can kind of take it off it's
taking it off
no it stays like it's taking it it's a
flight going on in the house
it's not like bad law but it's a
noticeable next
yeah but you know shout out to aaron
greenberg and the team
for making that a reality yes because it
started off as a little joke
and they embraced that joke and that's
something me and attic talked about
and um you might get little craig teddy
bears soon
y'all keep messing around yeah that's
kind of crazy
they embraced it they took it up and the
last thing i want to say about it for
those who don't care about the fridge
option you literally can just use turn
the lights on do the thing and
it you don't have to use it as a fridge
and don't have that noise going on so
that'll stuff but um it's off you want
to get these super chats now because i
know they're going to come in fast
furious and then we'll get right to mike
and get busy absolutely let me just copy
and paste this last one no doubt and
then while you're doing that i could do
some shout outs for um
uh some merch last week shout out to
phoenixdown318 he got the classic
pullover hoodie he said shout out to the
best xbox but not really an xbox podcast
i love having both series x and x
consoles it amazes me how well little
man keeps up and forza horizon halo and
destiny he got that little man hoodie
king he got that little man hoodie
you know what's funny we was playing
with someone i can't remember who it was
but
i i think it might have been
i don't know if someone with a pc okay
we were sitting there he was like he was
having such an issue starting the game
because it kept crashing and i was like
i was like look at that i was like hey
ain't that some stuff he's like what i
was like that he's like i spent all this
money you know i want to use it uh to
play the game to the best of the ability
i was like with someone that bought a
little man's you is playing that game
too better than you are right now i was
like how does it feel someone spent 300
dollars playing the game in your ass
over here without the game
we ain't trying to get the advice out of
it
but anyway oh real quick um then we got
a brick house arch he got the uh classic
10k iopt uh he said been a fan of you
since i found out about cargo and
defining dude oh salute also just got
the halo infinite series x and been
playing halo all week my ps5 is is going
to collect dust while i wait for horizon
you messy you messy salute but he's
telling the truth and i respect i
respect the honesty sir how is he
telling the truth
we have a lot of dudes that be in the
chat they'll be lying to themselves they
like they join it's not going to collect
them i mean if if you if you've had a
ps5 since launch
then though yeah you you've been talking
about it in the beginning but
right now yeah you probably are waiting
for them
i'm
[Applause]
my ps5 is totally in my closet
anyway let me finish the birch and then
we get this off um yeah then we got uh
laura maya my roof he got the classic t
no doubt salute to you my boy dalek
x he's got the um unicep zip hoodie
started watched a little over a year ago
and now i can't stop watching you guys
are the embodiment of all that is good
in gaming oh wow never changed love you
guys salute he got the hoodie no doubt
now we all caught up with the burst off
the super chat so then let's keep him
push her back
all right i was gonna say we're gonna
have to eventually make a shirt that
says not an xbox player yeah
the best not an xbox okay
with me in the background like
[Music]
with a new member liam ryan let's put
the crest in the chat for liam riley
race your brother salute the crosstalk
then we have tyson buhajo okay three
dollar super chat best guess to help my
night shift get hyped yes mike mike
mike is a walking energy drink yes yes
absolutely now we got tony bryant five
dollar super chat happy holidays lord
lords and realm welcome snow bike mike
no doubt this is going to be a great
holidays
absolutely wow this is going to be a
great show cog reign in your drivatar
yeah man
that's it i told you it's a physical
sport
let's get some lights get the lights up
what's up no doubt then we have evan p
10 super chat finally got a chance to
catch y'all live this podcast is always
a must listen to on sunday for me when
i'm at work toss thanks for the great
entertainment and info who's gonna bend
the knee today oh salute no doubt
then we got hard to find two dollars
with a chat mike how much money have you
spent on quote unquote free halo
my you know what i might i might be like
my boy king i might have swiped the card
a couple of times no i'll tell you what
i'm not looking at you i'm looking real
far out in there right now okay i look
real good
my
i was i was doing the math blaise spent
over 300 yeah
i see you out there boy i see you about
that i saw him with the little [ __ ]
that got the fire
[Laughter]
keep in mind it's a little after 8 a.m
where mike's at and he's already hired
yesterday absolutely
early morning let's go for sure
then we have lucious augustus 5 super
chat love halo hate the progression and
customization i just want to put any
coating on any armor core is that so
hard to ask
we'll get into it we'll get into it
we'll get it to it
and we got hargie cheney member for six
months shout out to heart geek loot
snow bike mike in the realm give thanks
for another lord's day on thanksgiving
weekend hope you had a great
thanksgiving now you can get back to
bashing halo for having a battle pass
okay
ashley's partner she's absolutely my boy
khalif started there i'm keeping it
pushing go ahead
then we got gaming forte ten dollars
super chat homie
hope everyone had a great thanksgiving
your boy is ready for a day off for
ieltsp is here to see me through oh
appreciate you buddy you need a day off
that boy is working salute the fourth
time you gotta get working hard
shout out to snow bike mike plus hashtag
no destiny for the third week oh we
gonna call turkey like me yeah
sometimes they gotta get it together
yeah halo's outside right now that's all
you know my boob bag
and as always hey king boo boo
aka
just like he said i haven't played
destiny probably a month and a half
build up yeah let's keep it pushing
y'all want to know how long has been i
played destiny
17 five five super chat opened the book
of x yesterday to read the definition of
desert and guess what the application
fell out
you're messy
get slow get slow let me let me get slow
where's slo hold up uh ps5 has no game
sorry um
then we got all the black conflict x let
me roll back a little bit we got slow mo
back slap two dollars with jack shout
out to the comeback cam
he was with us we were the big team
battle we was down 0-2 capture the flag
with about a minute 30 hold off for
three straight and it was slo-mo was it
on pc it was me shot the megatron was in
there locked that was a different game
that was a different game but someone
was with us when they were zero we were
zero and one and they we had 10 seconds
left yes
they did so much damage i was able to
drive that new vehicle up like right
between everyone
grab the flag and put it on the back and
just drive away it was one of the
greatest we all was cheering like it was
one of the greatest comeback moments get
like two more and then we move on
so there's only a couple ways oh there's
only a couple of guys we got black
conflict action oh that's my big he got
over the struggle
for black catholic he outside
outside
you you just like hearing my name yes we
do yes we do we love you we love you
salute brother we rep it
then we got lord metroid 2
watched adam play shinobi last friday
yikes
all right the disclaimer okay i'm gonna
defend at it
why is this first dude keep killing me
shout out to addict
he played it on the emulation way too
hard in the arcade settings we're gonna
do an official do-over that was we gonna
do it right and i'm gonna be there
because he gonna let me know cause i'm
the shinobi king and we're gonna do it
right so we're gonna do a rematch stream
y'all don't worry about that but i got i
gotta play battle toes this friday yeah
i know
there we go spartan goes once again two
pound super chat jack in boys the best
podcast is here
thank you thank you thank you
quick we got jacob j remember for five
months shout
co-host of the addicts show no doubt i
have the sentinel skin on on h.i
infinite i couldn't be looking like
actually in these streets
[Applause]
[Music]
so look we got everything caught up um
set the rules of engagement because you
already know yeah you guys know what it
is like we have a guest here we gotta
respect the time we have as much time to
talk with mike and ask about his journey
and everything so uh any super chats
from this point forward will be read
afterwards thank you very much doubt you
know what i'm saying so anyway so now we
got into what the laws were playing we
got to focus on snow bike mike his video
game system history his journey into
concrete content creation and shout
casting and of course what led him to
join a kind of funny and hosting that
amazing kind of funny x cast so lord
mike let's start from the very beginning
what was some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming
well uh what got me in the game let's
start off with the beginning right i'm a
90s kid so i grew up with aladdin's
arcade as many of us did going to the
arcade way back in the day putting in
all my quarters and then actually it was
my cousin peter showed up one day on a
family vacation with a black sega and
i've never seen it before right and we
plugged in aladdin i'll never forget
holding that boomerang controller and
thinking what the heck is this right and
from that point forward we were all
about talking about video games looking
for video games and like i said i'm a
90s kid right so we grew up every friday
going to blockbuster looking for games
and you know i have my n64 for my
childhood right behind me i'm a gauntlet
legends rampage world tour what ken
griffey jr baseball right here hold on
let me keep that up get up wow
right now wait mike is that wrapped
yeah it's wrapped up and everything's
like this plastic seal around it looks
nice wow
and so for me you know i always love
doing show and tell so i'll bring up a
bunch of props but i was an n64 kid
growing up and then of course that
evolved into the original xbox going
over i always tell the story it began i
really got lucky where one of my good
friends aj had an older brother who's
probably three years older than us so it
was competitive from the beginning right
halo 1 to halo 2. two different rooms
filled with kids screaming at each other
and another one me and paris like to
bring up is i grew up in the age of
couch competitive not couch co-op so we
played nfl street mad at ncaa nba live
and 2k where you would lose friendships
over interception
i'm gonna bring you back okay so i'm
just gonna get to the space that i like
it's gonna be
like
but
all right so you have the nintendo 64.
yup and this is when i learned a lot of
things all right you know silicon
graphics workstation stations we heard
that they will be using that type of
chip it was ultra 64.
he was following in in the magazines
before you got it right
oh no i was too young for that we must
be in elementary school so this was like
a holiday gift and we just attached
ourselves and loved yeah yeah so did you
get super mario 64. no so fun thing
about it for you king i never played a
single first party uh nintendo game
except for like smash bros and mario
kart but like zelda you know we're
talking mario any of those games i've
never played them even still to this day
i haven't really played wow
yeah yeah got a big nintendo black hole
of my life right now
i don't know like where i would be
gaming wise if it wasn't for like the
legend of zelda franchise
wow that's interesting that's that is
the most interesting thing
that i've heard because you know usually
and they say exclusive cell consoles
right but you are the anomaly here or
the the enigma i guess in this sense
that you had a nintendo console which
primarily lives and breathes off of the
fact that it's a you know first-party
exclusives and you were third-party
playing
on your nintendo 64. you said nhl you
showed ken griffey jr
the wrestling games
yeah that is absolutely mind-boggling no
doubt
right so yeah when we grew up that's
what it was it was like all third-party
games but now i come back with knowledge
and stuff i can say that and like
understand that fully right but like
truly honestly we never played any zelda
any mario it was oh man we are playing
these like diff clay fighters right
celebrity death match we're playing some
of the weirdest games and none of the
classics
i did play glover i did have glover oh
yeah for sure salute that is very
interesting
that's that's amazing i do have to break
protocol one time soft because i rarely
see a mid head i got a shot shout out to
the legendary jeff grub games mess up in
here he said respect mike's time
i had to bring photos
it's funny because when he when he wrote
it like that i'm like is that really
grub no that's that's the grudge that's
the grub i already know grumpy girl
to the best man in the game yes yeah
shout out to the gloria's here oh shout
out to l'oreal hair products
that's about business i love me so jeff
grubs
it's funny you say that mike because we
got us we gotta sleep on one part
because the part that i liked is you
said that like your parents came from
the couch co-op
competitive thing and the part where it
it really pushed friendships and the
physicality of cop obviously someone's
right next to you but also the fact that
like you said you're playing the madness
you're playing these games and like we
remember like you those are the
arguments be like yo you looking at my
screen
yeah yes yes you don't say like did you
had those moments where it got a little
you know a little testy or maybe just so
competitive with the games that you're
playing that you mentioned
oh of course lord you know that i mean i
i'll never forget ncaa football broke up
friendships right being the gators
versus the texas longhorns or anybody
else of like it was on from the moment
go right and even still to this day i'm
very competitive when i play games and i
know a lot of my friends if they were to
tell you they hate playing games against
me because i love just rubbing it in
their faces
they're definitely that guy that's right
you would giggle we play nba 2k and i'm
about to give it to you all game long
okay
let me ask you a question did you have a
dream cast
never had a dream cast never had a dream
cast notice how king tries to keep
making it older than it actually is no
dreamcast what about an indie yes
you know listen he says he had these
concepts except that he
if he's a sega kid right i'm thinking
and then cogs said you know about that
looking at my screen because my first
thing was going to say was um
the dreamcast uh had the little vmu yep
and he was able to pick this is that's
how they blocked out the fact that you
know somebody looking at your screen you
were able to pick your plays in madden
and all these stuff on the vmu so they
didn't see the plays that you was able
to pick that was a big one that was kind
of big in that oh that's cool you know
it was funny like we all i always had
that mentality you can look at my screen
don't mean you can stop what i'm doing
oh that's true that's true
i mean listen we have we'll jump to it
when he talks about xbox but like four
player halo there's a lot of screen
cheating going on oh thank you oh for
sure yeah we already know nobody's
screen cheating no matter what you say
dude
real quick boy hustler motivate he did
ask by he if you did play golden eye at
all of course oh you did okay okay she
didn't miss out with golden okay yeah so
of course goldeneye was a lot i actually
preferred perfect dark i know a lot of
people are very torn on that of course i
love gold knives don't get me wrong but
i really did enjoy perfect dark and what
they added right that was one of the
first games i've ever experienced bots
in so you put lots into your local
multiplayer game the laptop gun the
aliens it just kind of felt like it
pushed goldeneye to the next level which
i really enjoyed and did you know i'm
sure a lot of people tell you world's
not enough the next game on that blue
cartridge i loved that with james bond
that was a killer game as well no doubt
did you ever play any of the mario
parties
yes uh we played we played one or two of
them one or two not many of them but
yeah one or two i can remember for sure
so then we transition again you say so
from you genesis was kind of the first
one the boomerang control or whatever
kind of very young though very young so
you're just happy you don't kind to be
in the mix then you i would say 64 then
really kind of
you kind of as far as you and friends
really playing out a little bit more and
then now let's get right to that
transition you were talking about which
was you're saying from xbox and like how
did that whole thing happen
yeah that happened so xbox released 2001
i would have been 11 years old wow and
so that was like
xbox and playstation 2. you would have
been a preteen and games were really
coming to the forefront at that time for
me and my friends and so when i think
back to that era it comes down to xbox
right you look back and you think of
brute force you think of fusion frenzy
we were playing some fantasy star online
game that i can remember distinctively
and now i look at the new one i'm like
that was the game i played when i was a
child that's crazy you know you think of
guitar hero with your friends down in
the basement and just shredding that
plastic guitar and how much fun that was
gonna get enough credit yeah no that's
really special and so yeah at that time
it was the original xbox and then you
know we start to move into this period
of like ps2 and xbox 360 right and that
was kind of we're moving into high
school and now i can really have vivid
memories of everything and you think
back of gta right you brought him to the
definitive edition earlier
like that's a special one to me of like
we grew up with gta 3
vice city and san andreas i always tell
the fun story of like we were playing
that when we shouldn't have right that
was when it was on the news of like yo
hide this from your kids you should not
be letting them shout out to hot coffee
i was those i were those kids you know i
mean you were not supposed to let those
kids have that game and i'll never
forget i tell the story on the podcast
of like gta was very transformative and
special to me as a gamer where i saved
up every single dollar i got for lunch
for like three months straight like just
putting dollars away not eating at
middle school just so we could go and
get grand theft auto vice city the day
it dropped and i stood outside of a
circuit city and i begged people to buy
it for me and like mind you i must have
been like 12 to 13 years old people were
walking by like i'm not buying that for
you and sure enough we would buy some
college kid walked in yeah tell me [ __ ]
no this is amazing like like you went
outside running a campaign for people to
buy you this game
yo that is the most gangster thing i've
ever heard like salute to you on
this daddy
comes up okay
and so the college kid comes up and i'm
like hey man like i want this game and
he smiled and goes yeah sure bro and i
handed him my hard earned like i started
for this 65
and like you look at it now it's like
that kid could have just easily walked
away
don't do that in new york
he comes back with a big smile on his
face and goes have a great time kids and
i remember looking at my friend going
it's on right i show up at home and my
mom's like what is this i'm like don't
worry about it don't worry about it like
don't look at it right and there it is
right you got the music you can think of
mj all that the motorcycles and yes so
that was a really special time and it's
fun jumping back into definitive edition
where i can tell
those stories and remember those moments
of like putting on the infinite sheets
for the stars i can remember every
single mission every single road i can
think of the times where we used to pass
the controller right like now we're all
in this virtual world we're not together
but we used to sit down on the couch and
be like you get a death i get a death
yeah give me that back now i get it you
get it and so yeah that was a very
special time so i think of grand theft
auto and i think of halo those were the
two like big ones and of course those
sports games i mentioned but halo 2
i remember i didn't have an xbox at that
point so we would go to aj tessera's
house and i tell the story all the time
of like there's the two rooms right high
schoolers versus the middle schoolers
and then we move together but like
screaming and yelling and i'll always
tell the story is nobody ever wanted to
be
ajt one right you never wanted to you
could you ain't got your own yeah
exactly so you wanted your own ranking
you wanted this name yes and i didn't
have the xbox at the time but i got a
free seven-day trial and i begged gina
tesserrero to make me her own account
and she busted out her credit card she
filled out all the info for me
mike playing a lot of basketball
and won basketball taking over
[ __ ] def jam vendetta we're talking
nba street nfl street so that was like
young street baller mike and that was
the rise of sick nasty 22. oh sickness
oh you were sickness that was the name
that's right so so all right so
nba streets um okay so
a lot of you dudes may not know what n1
basketball
all this stuff started from the ruckus
right right let's go all right shout out
to rucker park and shout out to you know
king towers and all this other stuff
staying up
i i will be going to these um
these basketball courts and yeah i don't
i don't play ball
i i i literally i cannot play ball i'm
like i'm a bru i'm a brute no but you're
trying to rebound like hell oh yeah yeah
i'm dennis rodman yeah yeah you as robin
outside yeah just stand under the rim
but everybody that saw me thought i
bowled yes right so i will be hanging
out with future i will be hanging out
with with all these dudes that you see
on the m1 mix tape master bra
i knew all these things awesome all
right so
now
he said and won
when and one took off and they came out
with that game
mike did you run out and get that
because i ran out of got that he got it
you know i got it i was gonna say if i
started looking through all these games
i got him in the back that's right
you can bowl right
what was you a point guard forward
shooting guard what were you point guard
and shooting guard back in the day what
was the handle give me that handle
what was it sick nasty 22 and then my my
two on two teammate in the streets was
the prophecy so is the prophecy in
sicknasty
we got to get into because we rarely get
a chance to do at least i do you know no
is that
you know the the presence of sports and
online gaming and just like that was the
thing you know the tournaments the
competitive aspect of it you don't mean
trying to get better in this game and i
remember names like that when you you're
facing a guy with those type of days
like yo dude nice you know what i'm
saying like show time yeah mr show that
those days king right
our joints were um
uh nba live we
grew up on nba live right yes jordan
versus bird and being live now even
before that lakers versus celtics and
all that too late versus celtics
now basketball was over there
remember before they stole that from
turbo grove turbo had to take it yeah
all right so
um were you an allen iverson fan that
was a huge island
for the crossover what he brought to the
game how he changed he brought street to
basketball right now now what i'm what
i'm visualizing with you is that you use
that crossover dude
and when you when you're playing
basketball
you put what you put 99 on here what was
your dribble rating what was your
dribble rate oh you know that speed and
handles baby all the time
to 11.
do you remember being able to create
your character in madden and mba and
hockey and just taking those attributes
and cranking them to the next level like
oh what a special time that was you know
what a good one so continue your journey
brother you're playing these games
you're doing these guys yeah i mean so i
look at halo and grand theft auto i
think of all the sports games right you
brought up a great one of like i was nba
live that was the jam back then right
nothing was more fluid fast nothing felt
like basketball quite like nba live back
in that early 2000s and i will never
forget a great story for you is uh two
ones looking back on the xbox museum
they just had my first ever game i
booted up on that xbox 360. nba live nba
level six and i had that much lane wade
yes
very special to me and then i think of
the transition and i'll never forget
that moment of
nba live 08 that was my jam i loved that
game that would have been me as a
junior in the senior year of high school
and i'll never forget i thought i had
game king right i was like i'm the
baddest [ __ ] on the stage
and so i looked and i had a buddy and he
was like i'll bet you fifty dollars
let's play and i was like dude that's
the easiest fifty dollars i got let's
let's go right he's like but the cat
chases i play 2k and that was a game i
never played before i was like oh okay i
don't play 2k i play nba live and he's
like no we got to play 2k and i'll never
forget going to his house and now you
know i got the lump in my thought i'm
like i don't think i got this right and
i learned a valuable lesson on that day
about 2k what it was all about the
fundamentals took a big l lost by fifty
dollars but that felt like the changing
of the guard yeah that's when you found
out right exactly and that was from that
point forward it was 2k all day right i
think of 2k 10 to where we are today
right i have
i have 2k cutouts in my house you know
so yeah you remember the time
that uh 2k undercut ea for 19.99 that's
before yeah way back too yeah
and that's that's when all right so
a lot of you guys may not understand
this right it was a heavy competitive
situation when nfl uh
uh i forgot the name of the franchise uh
man it was madden versus 2k5
yeah and they had basketball and had
football
but to undercut the bigger ea which was
dominant they slashed the price to 20
bucks yes
now it became a value proposition yep
and and it was the better and it was the
better game and it greatly looked better
yeah
so all right so mike you knew that day
when you went over to the house you lost
your 50 bucks whatever it's gone but you
knew that day that you wasn't going back
to life
i knew it was the end of life forever
there right i just knew it and it's
crazy because we fast forward and you
saw that in real time right we all
experienced that of like it truly you
talk to your friends and they're like oh
i play 2k now and you're like wow really
and like the graphics the gameplay
everything went to 2k and i look back on
announce like yeah that was the end of
nba live and i experienced that
firsthand which is wild to think about
it is it is i i'm glad you mentioned
this because people don't realize i know
now we're in a world where 2k is what 2k
is right it's an event every year
everybody's going in you're on my you
know on my court you're out there paying
at it
you know making your suit fly and all
that to get that but the reality was
nba live was so dominant for so long so
to see them kind of knocked out to the
point where they really haven't been
able to make a substantial comeback to
really compete
yeah they and they have the license so
it just goes to show you how things can
change but yeah that's a great point i
do remember those days and i remember it
would have happened with the nfl
if ea didn't say oh hell no um
like it was it was like a lannister move
like they just
sent out regards okay so okay
no it was it it was that's in our
regards because it was one of those
things was like they had the inferior
product bro but they had the the bigger
pocket yes and it was just a matter of
we're gonna bully you out of this of the
game and take the license exactly and
take the license yeah and it was like
little bank yeah and then and then
little bank tried to release again a
superior playing game the following year
without a license
oh it was like oh jerry rice john elway
yeah
yeah they said i'm playing with the new
york raiders
the new york buck back yeah
it was it was it was not exactly you
realize
the importance of licenses
yeah we're going to continue your
journey circuit
yeah i mean uh just sticking with that
really quick before i continue on is
when we look at ea now and we look at
the nba world and like how do you do
what do you do to compete against 2k i
continue to yell about it on the podcast
i know gary and paris love it it's like
bring back ea big and put on nba streets
right clearly you're not going to win in
the simulation side yes like put on a
fun arcadey one i agree we saw 2k try to
do playgrounds and that was not a good
experience so like do nba street bring
it back i don't know why they're so
afraid to do it but they know they could
and it would hit so i look forward to
seeing what ea wants to do one day
especially trying to get that that base
established before 2k decides to to take
another shot at that again
it is plenty of time to to locking that
down
it is very weird that they haven't
capitalized the way on like they haven't
capitalized on lebron james they haven't
capitalized on a lot of these these
stars in in a way like they did back in
the day whereas jordan was in everything
right well not jordan specifically yeah
it was funny
but what i mean is
to kind of appease all these different
types of gamers right you would think
they know they're going to make money
hand over fist
so why they only want to focus on the
simulation game is a little weird to me
you want to you know you want to know
why
and i can tell you why
when the ea when when when basketball
association cleaned up the sport
took out uh the individuality of the
players
a little bit of that died
because
that's that's what the nba had the nba
had the individuality of you had alan
ivanson you had little penny you had
shaq you had these individuals that were
turning up like you when you saw allen
iverson and his entourage and the gold
change and the stuff like that it makes
little kids or teams say man he is
absolutely cool i want to be that when
the nba cleaned them up and they wearing
jeans and suit jackets with ashy ankles
you know when they we stopped wearing
jerseys when when jay-z it was pop
culture yeah so when jay-z and these
guys say oh button-downs and they went
back from jerseys the nba took a
different turn so when y'all say y'all
want streets and all that stuff back
i don't think they're gonna go there
because i don't really think the nba
talks to the urban youth at this moment
yeah but but it is it didn't galvanize
the money i feel when you say it but
it's one of those things that i think if
they if a legit attempt is made kind of
what mike is saying like
i do think that like they'll be
surprised like put it this way it real
quick i know we didn't have tommy but
yeah
you know obviously shout out to back
compat we had jason ronald on last week
right right you know i was amazed 50
cent blunderson came back that's
ridiculous
so i thought it was just for licensing
all that to see me post one clip of this
game
and this thing goes yo i remember oh my
god so it's like the hip hop the that
there's a culture that is really
yearning for these type of games that
represent them you know what i'm saying
so if it's done right i think they do
have a legit shot you know what i'm
saying to kind of monetize it but to
your point king there may be a fear of
dipping into that bag once again get at
it i'm sorry i i think i think all of
the real quick i think all of the
professional sports are starting to lean
back into it though because i know what
you mean king and that's 100 right but
when you look at baseball right baseball
the past couple of years has been a big
sort of pushback on the young players
you know being quote unquote
disrespectful you're not playing the
game right yeah you're not playing
you're not hustling you hit a home run
and you drop the bat you're doing all
kinds of stuff why are you staring at
the disrespectful but there there's a
movement saying you know what this is
their game now let the kids play the way
they play let them play their title let
them talk their smack yeah it's all
going to settle itself out in the end
right so i i don't think baseball i
don't know we're going to get like a
like you know an artistic slugfest again
okay oh my god remember these guys yeah
but the thing is i do think that they
kind the fear of it is going away a
little bit because they know there's
money in that mm-hmm
i think
a lot of has to do with ea's pride i
feel like if they feel like they can't
compete with 2k in in that area they're
not trying to go the other area like
because if you notice like they bring
live back every couple years
they can smack down again
like i feel like they're like if we
can't take on 2k we ain't doing nothing
in basketball too yeah they want the
biggest piece but back-to-back man we
got to refocus yeah i mean it's well
done i'll keep it focused but yeah the
optics right my friend always says it's
like i miss nfl blitz i miss nhl hits i
miss nfl street he's like mike the
optics nowadays with cte and player
injuries and pushing people like we
don't do that mike and i'm like man but
do you remember back in the day when i
used to suplex you like
the place and he's like yes mike but we
don't do that anymore
the optics unfortunately might not ever
lead to those but those are some
memories i'll always have and like you
know keeping it going when we get into
the xbox 360 area that's like prime high
school mike right and this is at a time
where i'm juggling basketball full-time
school of course and trying to be the
best i can be but also like you're
talking about halo 2 in the gears of war
right that's 2016 and like cliffy b is
bringing something that we've never seen
something like almost kind of ultra
violet like we've seen on computer
trailer i'm not really on console that
trailer right cog that you could still
put on it people don't have kills
thinking about it right that was
probably the best video game trailer
that i've ever seen marketed from music
because
shout out to the great peter moore and
everybody green lightning
oh my gosh
there's so many stories i i should tell
there right i think of the xbox 360
launch and that was prime mic of like
mom i have to have this we need this
right and like she's like you're like 14
turning 15. do you really need something
like we have to stand outside circuit
city together you know what i mean
get out of school there's me and mom on
a fall chilly winter's evening boulder
colorado right freezing to death outside
she don't want to be there i'm begging
to be there and i'll never forget
leaving her at 8am to go to school the
next morning and being like don't mess
this up mom i need you and she's like
we've been here for 13 hours like i'm
not going to mess it up okay so she said
you're not missing school like you're
going to go
you can stay here all night but you're
going right absolutely
shout out to mom for that right i think
of the 360 launch i think of the moments
like i say basketball was big for me and
that was me and my friends every day
after school
waiting for our freshman or sophomore
gym time after varsity right where we
would play games and like do homework
and then go to school and then meeting
my fun story i always tell is where we
bridged the gap and i learned that
gaming as universal was coach nick okay
his father was the head coach of cu
at the time the university and he was
fresh out of washington state playing up
there so he's a young kid probably 25
right he's young he's here he's cool
probably the coolest kids we've ever met
we're a bunch of squares right and he
overheard us we liked video games he's
like what's up i like video games too
and i looked at them and it's just like
the nba live moment again i was like
well i freaking bring it in college
football how about we battle right now
if i win we never do sprints for a week
if you win we'll sprint right now and
like everybody gathered i'm carrying in
my xbox at 7 30 at night and like we're
battling and it was like we talked about
couch competitive where we're chirping
in the locker room we're laughing and we
built this bond me and coach nick where
it's like man like this guy is older
than us but he's down with games i
didn't know that right like we're just a
bunch of high schoolers so that was a
really special moment and then we get
into halo 3 and the launch of halo 3. my
first ever midnight launch right here
your first one
yeah you're a senior in high school you
have the car keys you can do whatever
you want right and like i looked at mom
and dad i was like i'm going i'll see
you all in a little bit i'm out there in
a line full of people i've never met
that all shared the same thing
toward games with me right kids are
screaming and getting excited and i've
never seen this right it was wild yeah i
honestly don't think people like
i always enjoy like remember like the
the midnight launch
yeah and like i think that that's done
especially
pandemic that that's over like i
remember going to like like call of duty
midnight launches and
there would be
so many people there
when they started robbing people yeah
that was good
when you saw the police outside
i think i think i honestly went to like
one of the last biggest ones that was
there that was gta 5.
yeah when i was to get when i when i
went to get my ps4 right i was
it the mall that's close to here right
the game stop opens out onto like
basically the highway right so it's all
dark back there so when i went in
earlier in the day to make sure that you
know the
pre-order was all set whatever the guy's
like yeah the cops are gonna be here
don't worry about it whatever they're
gonna be they're gonna be cabs outside
so you can just hop in the cabin if you
don't have escape i i grab my ps4
at midnight and i walk into this black
abyss right there's nothing there's
nothing over there
oh i'm like so i'm like calling uber i'm
like the uber's like 15 minutes away
while you're in the shop when you want
to wait in the shop and then call it bro
i ran when that uber pulled up you don't
know how i ran to that car because it's
like it was just it you have to be very
careful now you got to be here
new york city is crazy
it was crazy
since people up here are like so
pro-gun like
[Laughter]
around the place i live like the
virginia and west virginia area like one
of every three people have a gun yeah so
y'all y'all be rolling to the game like
who what what with your mic mike the
statistics here is one out of every
three have a good but it's not legal
here
no no that's like here one out of three
people legally have guns i don't know i
don't know
this is the transition right
we were being teased and and mike
eloquent at a great point
it was a 25 year old uh coach that
played
so so this is the transition
when you were younger
we were looked at as the nerves of
squares like you said the squares
all i know is squares that plays these
games grand theft auto
changed
that mentality
and halo had a hand in that yeah because
from our aspect
halo had the drug dealers on the corner
with tv outside he got people off the
street you know in the front of the
store we don't
we we give gta a lot of credit and they
deserve it and i love how gta like how
their pr team is it's like
like it could be like the worst case
scenario they're like it's still good
publicity for us like they it feels like
they don't care
what i've always felt like we don't give
this franchise and i know i don't like
this franchise okay i don't like this
franchise at all
but i feel like halo made first-person
shooters
a lot more like mainstream and yeah
yes absolutely but i feel like call of
duty lifted it to the sky
i don't think gaming would be where it
this is the transition
see mike was in that transition point
where he acknowledges what he saw
he saw a older hipper dude
i was in charge of the kids yeah that
had the same passion and love that he
had right and then you you started
talking about the line where all these
people that shared your passion this is
the change though
call of duty halo and grand theft auto
took the urban
into our space
so all the dudes that was ridiculing us
are now on that line
yeah and that's the thing yeah a lot of
these thugs realize these squares got
money and we could take their stuff oh
this is
[Laughter]
okay that's the chance this is where
fear factor happened
so this is this is where sovereign can
actually
solving is no slouch solving wrestles so
literally if he give up he gets a hold
on your shoulder your arm your leg your
foot or something like you can't wrestle
with a console in your head
for your necks
undefeated at that point listen i don't
want anyone to think that sovereign is a
slop
the mentality he knows where he's at
like attic said one in three in west
virginia i'm not going to be attic for
yeah i mean
that was the moment where i was like oh
man like i'm around a lot of other
people that are into this right that's
the early days of the internet right and
there's kids who were really into that
and you comprehended the internet you
were typing away yeah there were kids
like me who were like i understand the
internet i've used that before but like
that's not my day-to-day right so i
didn't see you know articles i didn't
see videos that wasn't my thing back
then it was a lot of sports and so that
was an eye-opening experience and that
also led to what we'll get into in a
minute of like going off to college but
returning
from day one of halo 3
multi or halo 3 launch night right
looking over at a kid i've never spoken
to in high school right and his head is
down on the desk i'm tired and i looked
at him he looked to me he goes halo 3
and i was like halo 3. you're bro all of
a sudden we built this connection i'm
like what's up i'm mike and he's like
i'm brad and i'm like oh my god like
i've never met you before in four years
i'm like that's cool right and so we
share these stories and so then that
leads on to freshman year of college and
i'm like any other kid going off to a
brand new location i told my parents you
know funny enough we talk about sports
right i had a couple of options one i
could stay at home with mom and dad and
go to cu boulder and do the same thing i
was doing two i got a scholarship
offership to go to rolling hills
nebraska to play like d3 community
college basketball
and i looked at my mom and dad i go
that's awesome but i ain't going to
nebraska cause that sounds like it sucks
and they started laughing and i go i
want to go to california where all the
cute girls are at for one thing it's
gotta have snow and they laughed at me
and they go well you know california
doesn't really have snow there's a lot
they pointed to a map and they left me
here in beautiful lake tahoe where i've
been for
my entire adult life right brother and
so there i go off on my own right i
didn't look at lake tahoe i didn't look
up the community college that i was
going to go attend i just went and
showed up with my xbox 360 and forged
bonds because of that right i am that
college dorm where you have the door
open people peeking or you're playing
halo or you're playing skate you're
playing fallout 3 like what's up and
bang i made friendships because of that
in this small town and gaming has always
been at the forefront whether it be
at the dorms or like me i started
working at 19 years old right away five
days a week balance in school and we
talked about it with that coach at 25
now i'm with grown adults right people
in their 20s 18s 30s 40s right and now
i'm learning oh snap there's people who
just like and talk about gaming right
that brought me together with a lot of
people and my co-workers that built
bonds yeah the biggest icebreaker i
think i have when it comes to like if i
if i come across someone's got like a
gaming shirt on or like oh yeah
that's like the easiest way to engage
the conversation
it's unreal yeah it'd be this is a great
story and i love what you said you know
even from back from the midnight launch
stuff then transitioning into your
career and and thinking about what you
want to do with your life and it's like
you said you know it's one of those
things that you see another gamer and
it's that unspoken bond right it's that
that yo that's family right there that's
what i do he do what i do and then you
just the whole that person looks
different you could have been walking
past that person or see that person a
zillion times but until that information
is fined out it's your gaming brother
and she gave his sister you know what
i'm saying that's your safety net right
like you know it you've all seen it
before whether it be at midnight
launches at conventions and it's so
easily said and a lot of people get
worried about it but like those people
standing next to you are there because
they love the same thing as you they're
enthused and excited about the same
thing and it's easy enough to be like
hey what's your favorite anime hey what
game are you into you like you like
defining duke and these guys what's up
right and like you will make friends for
a lifetime because of that and that was
me 19 years old all by myself working
full-time i didn't know what a true job
was like right like this is your first
work experience and those were my safety
nets those five people that i knew like
well i could talk games with them or
like i could connect with them better
and that led to a really great life with
that but gaming has always been at the
forefront awesome and i think around
2013 probably i must have been 23 that
would have been the time where i started
getting connected to the internet right
you start looking at ideas and
transitions i start to look into reviews
i learn about podcasts right and now i'm
listening to you know the ign suite the
you know game scoop the podcast beyond
with colin and greg that have a big you
know change in my life i'm listening to
ryan mccaffrey who is one of my gaming
heroes we talk about right
now i'm starting to learn about like oh
there's a games industry i didn't know
that right of like i don't know people
are getting paid to review or write
ricky guides or talk about games oh
there's youtube channels now right this
is a big eye-opening experience for me
and those guys were in my ears walking
to school walking to work i was
listening to all of these guys and gals
right and
you know that starts to build the thing
of like okay that's cool oh wow there's
this thing called twitch right that's
cool too i like twitch that's awesome oh
wow my favorite gaming personalities
from ign are going to quit their comfy
sweet jobs at this incredible games
media outlet and drop it all to go
create a twitch channel with just the
four of them and they all look like
idiots and there's no way this is gonna
work but i'm definitely going to go
watch them and check it out yeah and
that's where kind of funny becomes at
the forefront in 2015 for me right it's
like i rode with colin and greg i was
there with them and i liked them again
and i believed in that and so you
transition and you start to learn from
the people that you look up to or the
people that you really are influenced by
right what's this twitch thing why are
they on twitch what are they talking
about right and now i start to look at
everything right what is twitch oh man
look at these different people that are
broadcasting their gameplay right and i
think microsoft and xbox have done such
a great job at like trying to stay on
the wave right we'll talk about mixer
later on but like they brought to you
the opportunity to stream directly to
twitch
very early on and that was very
impressive without a bunch of equipment
needed they were like hey we'll let you
stream directly from the console and you
can just plug in your connect
chucks i had to connect they forced me
to buy one right so like we used it for
right now i got it up on my wall you got
that 1080p you had a height you know
what you would yeah and so
it was really really special at the time
and that's when
it went from gaming as a hobby to oh wow
that could be a job right and so as i
went forward in 2015 they had the first
ever twitchcon in san francisco and the
boys said they were going to attend and
i loved those guys and i was like i'm
gonna go see them and we're gonna see
what twitch is all about and so i
brought my girlfriend at the time i said
we have to go please come with me and so
it's an easy drive from tahoe down to
the bay and sure enough there we are and
once again it's another eye-opening
experience talking about thousands of
people yes gassed up to meet their
favorite broadcasters the play games on
the show floor this is my first ever
convention i didn't know we were doing
things like this right at that kind of
age and so we're talking
merch we're talking games we're talking
your favorite broadcasters and that's an
eye-opening experience to see they're
heroes colin and greg right who are my
heroes and they're small fish in the
pond compared to people who are walking
by and there's thousands of people
chasing after them right and you're like
wow this is really cool you're meeting
people in line it's like oh like i
i'm full-time content creating really
what do you do i just play minecraft oh
that's crazy you know to me i'm looking
at the kid that's crazy right
and so in 2015 i got to meet my heroes
greg colin tim and nick live right there
shook their hands told them how much
they meant to me watch two of their
panels and when we hopped in the car i
looked at my girlfriend at the time and
said you know i really like what they do
i think i could do that i play games
every night like why couldn't i do that
what was the moment to transition for
yourself yeah he looked right back at me
she goes why don't you do that that's a
good question let's figure it out right
and that night we get home i
back them on patreon and we'll talk
about that that was a big moment shift
in a moment but i backed them on patreon
at a certain level where i was going to
get face time with these guys it was
going to be really important to me and
also because i wanted to support them
right and then on the flip side we
figured out twitch we signed me up we
turned it on the xbox and if you look
back on my twitch archive in 2015 one of
the first games i ever played was mad
max live on twitch to literally my mom
and my girlfriend and that's all
that were there
a good fun game and like it was a really
cool time for me of like i'm 25 years
old and i can do anything in life just
like everyone at any age you have the
opportunity to shift passions and look
at anything right and i balanced a
girlfriend a full-time job i balanced
trying to stream and figure out what
that looked like to absolutely no one
right and it was this fun ride of
a couple of years probably two years in
between that of like me streaming every
now and then learning what that was
streaming to nobody but the catch was is
i was really getting in tight with kind
of funny with these opportunities and
i'll never forget they'll tell you the
story the same way
is they had a patreon tier where you
could support them and every three
months you could get on a skype call and
talk with your heroes for 10 minutes
right just
sitting here with iron lords podcast say
whatever you want to these guys dap them
up
pump them up listen to bob marley with
kim
whatever you want as we did at the
pregame
exactly and so
there i was i'll never forget the week
before it was my first time so my turn
to do it yeah they had a podcast about
like oh man these calls are so exciting
it's awesome for us as the creators to
see our fans right what the cat is is
like a lot of these kids are stunned
right like you're grasping for air
you're me yeah you're immediately
excited
you don't know what to say you're also
worried are you going to embarrass
yourself and so i remember thinking that
i was like okay like that would be me so
like what can i do different
and i'll never forget i drew up a mini
kind of funny podcast just like they
always did
we all gathered in the zoom call just
like this and i said everybody hey it's
nice to meet you i'm mike like can you
sit down be quiet and they're like what
is going on here and i was like one
second
and i turn and i go what is going on
everybody guys snow bike mike and this
is the first ever official kind of funny
best friend meet and greets i'm joined
by and i went down the line and they all
were stunned they just go
they looked about like what is happening
i was like here's the deal guys like i
wanted to make this fun so i got some
cool topics and of course you start off
with the easy icebreaker a bear versus a
gorilla who's gonna win right and they
just started laughing
and from that point forward i had
probably seven of these where every time
they would be they would make an event
like oh my god mike let's do it right
and then one of them looked at me about
the sixth time i was like are you
recording this and i was like no i'm not
recording this is just for me doing this
with you and they're like why aren't you
recording this this is unbelievable
right
i never thought of that and so i shared
moments with greg tim
nick where you know you're making these
connections and my first time ever
meeting colin moriarty was really
special to me right this is a guy i
looked up to this is a guy that was
special to me but also has a hardened
exterior if you've ever listened to
colin you're probably like oh man like
is this guy going to like me or he's
going to hate me
every single week
i'll never forget i was worried if colin
would be there right because i was
intimidated i was scared
and he never was there and then there
was one week where he showed up and it
was just him and greg and i remember
i had the lump in my thoughts
i was like here it is and so i
remembered colin's a sports fan right
clown's new york kid
colin knows everything but i told him
the story about somebody reselling
tickets outside of a rockies game and my
dad being from new york just straight up
stiff in this dude because he wouldn't
move down on price right no and colin
looked at me
giant smile and just immediately goes
into his stories about selling tickets
to the yankees games outside and like
remaking money so he could go in that's
real
connection right there and that's that
moment where you're like oh my god we're
all human we all have connections but
like i was lucky enough to have this
moment with him that was really special
to me and so these guys knew me right we
started to build this bond and you know
i always told him i was like hey i'm i'm
working up on the mountain and i love
doing what i do right i worked and
managed a restaurant at 21 years old
they handed me the keys and said good
luck which hey never should have been
yeah
a lot right like think of yourself at 21
years old olive low all alone right your
friends now are partying going to the
nightclub
they're working seasonal jobs where it
doesn't really matter right i could quit
jamba juice tomorrow i don't want to be
here right but then you now have a job
where it's like oh you got to be here
you know you got to run this right you
got to be there and i remember every day
thinking like oh i can't go to the club
or like oh man i have a responsibility
so my life started to change where i
took that leadership role early and i'll
never forget right you're 21 you're up
on top of a mountain at 9 000 feet at 7
30 in the morning nobody wants to be
there but it was my job to make you want
to be there and give me some sort of
effort right
and so i started to have this like
leadership and kind of hosting mentality
of like hey good morning everybody like
we got to do this together like let's
make this happen right and that kind of
started a segway into well there's what
kind of funny does this is what the
video game industry does i would like to
do that one day and so they knew my
passion started to shift towards like oh
i would be into that right
and so they knew that and i was blessed
because when you work at the mountain
everybody's there right in this small
town everybody's skiing or snowboarding
i worked at the largest lodge where we
hosted an opera ski party right we're
talking djs go-go dancers big fun
nightlife parties right and so
now i'm getting i'm rubbing elbows with
nightclub promoters i'm rubbing elbows
with a guy who oversees all of the
parties for northern nevada and tahoe
and he's the main host right they call
him the ryan seacrest of tahoe and i
believe that this guy drew meerum can do
anything right he was incredible and i
remember walking up to him one day and
it's like i'd like to do that what's up
and he looked at me with a big smile and
i'll tell you
anything is possible in life anything
you can do can happen and he flipped the
microphone he goes here we go let's do
it and i was like really he's like have
fun with it i mean this was my lodge i
don't know what was happening it's not
like it was new to me and he laughed it
was like hey i got some jobs if you want
to do them and so that led into me every
thursday night i hosted thursday night
karaoke at my blue casino and spa
i hated karaoke but i did it because i
was up for the idea right that gave me
the opportunity to host to
learn about the industry
the song you you can speak those songs
right yeah
you gotta really gotta do that whole
stupid dog falsetto this is tremendous
and one thing that i wonder how i got to
stop it for a second the one thing that
i got to highlight
is your hustler's spirit your ambition
and your fearlessness because a lot of
people
let's be honest king right when the
lights is on
it like a lot of people want opportunity
but then when it's presented they don't
they shy from it but they run from it
and they fall back and you embraced it
you you grabbed it by the horns and was
like look i'm gonna put myself out there
and even though i may be nervous i may
be i'm around all this craziness i'm
also around my heroes and i wanna i
don't know i wanna i don't want you to
cross over that story with with colin
and greg right cause we all all of us
are disciples for college greg what they
made were kind of funny and all the
stuff they did they breaking away from
ign which we all knew them followed them
for was amazing but to see you in front
of your heroes i know that feeling you
know so it's like i was the same way as
well with ryan you know what i'm saying
i was like i met him he stopped what he
was doing dropped his bag talk to me and
i'm just like yo i'm talking to ryan
right now this is like pre-ilp you don't
say like it's crazy so i know that
feeling and i want to give you your
flowers there because there's one thing
to say it but there's another thing that
actually do it and and put your best
foot forward and keep going yeah he had
those cojones those solid
balls if he will pause
from
the coach if y'all wasn't listening yeah
for the jump for him to tell the coach
i'mma bust your blood in this game with
that smoke right now we ain't doing no
more suicide
and you know what you you literally put
the team on your back because your team
you already had a cheerleading squad
right there yeah
you're already at this point already
that you already were that go get a dude
all right so when your parents did send
you away
to they had pure confidence in you right
yeah and they knew that you were going
to go there and you weren't going to um
poo poo your opportunity right
and at the same time
the manager at the the the restaurant
that they gave you the keys at 21 years
old store the leadership in you and the
responsible guy in you
and and he bet right yeah he better
right
you could have bungled
exactly your friends was going out
partying and stuff like that you had the
the the awareness to know i can't do
that i got responsibilities and i got to
do this so again so when that promoter
and that dj looks over at you they see
that in you yeah they see that go-getter
that willingness tremendous and it's in
every word that you say every word that
you said you have been telling people
you have not said the word can't yet
yeah yeah you've been saying can yeah
you can do everything so when people
actually take the five seconds to listen
to every word that's coming out of your
mouth and can't is not in your
vocabulary facts they know who they're
dealing with
so i knew who i was dealing with
every second that i listened to you yeah
of course you got those opportunities
and i want to i want to move forward too
because i want to transition obviously
now to that magic moment for you where
it's kind of like okay you're now
figuring it out this is what you want to
do i know you're doing all the
entrepreneurial stuff you're out there
in the town you know what i mean but you
are developing this passion for content
creation you are developing this passion
so like how does that transition now
happen from that to now becoming part of
kind of funny like to be getting on the
team like what's that about
yeah that was a big moment that's 2017.
okay and so there's two big pieces in
2017
that will start to change and shape my
life to where it is today and there's
the first one of course great miller
industries so greg had a dumb fun idea
where he was going to let somebody come
into the studio be right next to the
guys and delete his friends off of his
playstation account because he had too
many and he was like hey i got all these
people you got a no playstation i need
you and here's another one just like you
said i can't or being worried that
you're not good enough right he said i'm
going to put the call out you make a
video and i want to see if you want to
come down here and do this right he just
has a fun joke he's going to pick
somebody
there was three days later and everybody
had videos right and they were very
talented well-edited fun transition
videos i didn't know how to do anything
on adobe right i was a i've turned on
obs i'm gonna give you one take it stop
recording and i'm gonna upload it that's
right
that was me
and so you can find this up on my
youtube channel still to this day and i
recorded and sat right in front of the
computer and i hit record and i gave
them two and a half minutes of just me
hoping and having fun right and i sent
that off and i laughed going man i look
so bad compared to all these other kids
and yeah greg was kind of in favor of
people being near san francisco because
he wasn't going to fly people out right
but it was really cool because he chose
myself and two others and we got an
experience of a lifetime right that was
my first time in the studio that would
be my first time ever being on a podcast
as well i was going to be having fun
with them and so
that's when it started right 2017 in
october i went down there and i got to
be on a podcast i got to be behind greg
and colin deleting people off of his
playstation account right
and that took my twitch from my mom and
my girlfriend at the time to maybe 10
people right and now i felt like oh i
have some energy here i got the snowball
rolling let's do this and so i committed
to three nights a week okay friday
saturday sunday so mind you king here's
another one for you right all my friends
are partying i gave all that up for
years so i could be there during prime
time wow friday saturday sunday i was
going to be live and i'm also juggling a
full-time job that you had to be there
at 7 00 a.m so it started to look like
girlfriend work puppy dogs uh then you'd
show up and you'd stream for three hours
a night right and it'd be 10 people they
were all so good to me and we grew that
right and so now we're growing it's 2012
or 2019 and me and that team had become
close and they knew what my intentions
were they knew that i wanted to host and
they looked at me and they said hey
we're going to do kind of funny prom our
next live event do you want to host this
okay and i remember the phone call i
said are you sure you know because
they're previous hosts just so everyone
everybody knows bernie barnes of rooster
teeth troy baker of all of your favorite
video games and austin creed aka xavier
woods and they were like hey mike you
could join that and i was like yeah i
think you're making the wrong call but
i'm going to do this right like me
and so i got to host a kind of funny
problem that was my first ever 500 plus
arena where people were screaming and i
learned what it feels like to be up on
stage and get people excited and have it
so loud that you don't know what you're
even saying into the microphone anymore
because people are screaming right
and that was the moment that everything
changed that was probably 2019 and then
during that summer i paid for myself and
two friends to go to every convention
that we could we went to rtx e3 and pax
west all of our pennies together we paid
for hotels we sat together
and we went to twitchcon which was the
first one king and we went to an esports
slash broadcast host panel and the kid
never said it better right he looked
right at us and he said why aren't you
doing it right now
i looked at my friend i said why aren't
we doing this it's day one what are we
doing and he goes i don't know and the
guy said this is how it begins you grab
something and you do it now and i looked
at my buddy and i go we're going to best
buy and he goes why they go we're going
to buy a microphone and we're going to
do it now which might be sure
[Laughter]
we enough it to the iphone and sure
enough through the next two days at
twitchcon we ran around booth to booth
and i practiced just like i saw my
heroes do right naomi kyle andrea renee
all of the guys at e3 i emulated that
right hey what's going on everybody
we're at twitchcon i'm standing in front
of this booth with the bike that's how
kid gave me the bike was that game
people will think you're insane and
people will think you're dumb looking
but it is the most fun you'll ever have
and it will be the turning point for you
right and so we go from twitchcon now we
go to rtx we do the same thing we go to
pax west we do the same thing and this
is that transition of like don't be
afraid go try go have fun right and so
at that point we're getting a lot of
steam we're having a lot of fun and i'm
doing things that i'm passionate and
excited about and that leads to
december
2020 i think okay and that is when
the dumb idea is born of the kind of
funny ex-cast
gary whittaker looks at greg miller and
goes man y'all talk a lot about
playstation you all need an xbox live oh
gary was the one he goes he goes oh
really gary you want to do that and gary
looked at me goes yeah i want to do that
and he goes well who would host it he
goes yeah me and snow bike mike and bang
my phone starts blowing up when you hear
this what do you think and so they call
me they go hey we think this could be a
real thing would you like to do this and
i was like scared right kid you brought
it up right here's your moment are you
going to step up and do this in the
light and i said yeah i would love to do
this let's make it happen you go okay
we'll call you back we'll figure it out
six months down the road hey mike we're
ready let's make this happen we're gonna
put you gary and we're gonna put alana
pierce on the podcast and i was like
excuse me you got alana pierce to be on
the podcast and i was like yeah she's
gonna be there she's gonna help you grow
and learn and be your best and that was
how the kind of funny x-cast was formed
and born right and so i had the awesome
opportunity to be next to gary who i
have a lifelong friendship with like a
real dude two dudes you never thought
would be next to each other i'm hanging
out with gary all the time having fun
telling stories right
and alana pierce who looked right at me
and she said hey this is all about
having fun don't be afraid we're gonna
stumble we're gonna get up and we're
gonna have a great time and she was
there ride or die from the beginning
with me right and so i really got lucky
with gary and alana and now i'm even
more lucky with my two gaming dances i
like to call paris and gary right oh
shout out but that was the beginning is
right and so i know you want to ask
about shout casting and that's something
really near and dear to my heart so i
definitely want to bring that up but
that was the start it was that guy at
twitchcon and said why aren't you doing
this right now we stood up and we did it
salute salute tremendous drive passion
the fearlessness grabbing the
opportunity again you know i was
blessed to have the opportunity you guys
have invited me you know on to kind of
funny xcast and had an amazing time i
obviously shouted a lot i wasn't there
for her but you know she's a legend but
then obviously i got a chance to be gary
to paris and we had a great time you
guys run a great show it was really
tremendous to see that jordan was
amazing i do definitely want to get to
the shoutcasting because
um what i really respect about it like i
told you offline
is it's such a unique skill set
and king would probably and maybe solve
could appreciate even attic to some
extent because i've done it
i've been done shout casting officially
but what i've done is like being silly
with your friends and kind of narrating
yo all right go get the flag this that
and we play these games and i used to
love doing it right i used to love doing
that but it takes a different you know
on the fly adaptability you have to be
entertaining but shout casting over
events and people gaming i just watched
you always at the hype nation
invitational tournament my boy's killing
it he's out there you know and you're
like yo team red's pushing forward
they're going back so talked about that
skill set because what i'm doing in the
crib is nothing
that's just me playing around you know
like you are doing this like this is
some esports level quality
shout casting tell us about that passion
how did that start for you
you know that that starts as a kid and
everyone has done it right you've all
have commented over your buddy's
gameplay before right we've all done it
and so being so big into the nba at the
time right when you think about me in
the 90s do it early
exactly right you think
and so
in 2017 2k and the nba partnered
together to create what would be known
as the nba 2k league right and at the
time came we talked about it right i
thought i had game and i remember being
on stream looking at the camera and
going i'm going to dedicate myself i'm
going to make the nba 2k league well
three days later i quickly learned i
don't got that kind of game right
so i said to myself well what could i do
and i started to learn and i noticed
that a buddy of mine who you know hosts
alongside scott cole named dirk was
shout casting games and i was like well
i could i could provide commentary to
games i could do that and it opened up
my eyes to the call of duty league with
courage with maven right you look at
halo esports and all these different
names it's like oh that's a job too that
you could get into right and so in 2017
i got connected with some really awesome
people in the nba 2k world
o.g king kurt out of new york took good
care of me lt down in dallas took good
care of me nacho and big west and so the
names go on and these guys gave me an
opportunity they said hey we host
community tournaments we would love for
you to cast that what do you think i
said yeah i would love to and a lot of
people don't know back in 2017 and 18
there was no matchmaking in 2k so these
teams would go into
the gym and hope that they somehow match
made with each other amongst thousands
of games and so it was my job not only
to intro but to keep things interesting
enough while these teams match made fail
to match make reload into the game go
back to the gym reload it'll be five
hours of broadcast and we've only played
three or four games right it was insane
amount of time to sit around and twiddle
our thumbs and so i learned a lot there
and that actually led me into one of my
dreams and when i uh something i'll
never forget i got to work with nba
teams right i have a check from the
philadelphia 76ers that's framed up on
my wall right now right i've worked with
the shuttle which i would have
the dream come true you know me small
little white boy i'm not making the
league but like it was my dream right my
my my little known fact um my
ex-girlfriend uh i was on the father's
day and it was a father's day meet and
greet lunch and we had a bread and
breakfast and we met allen iverson
salute wow yo
yo
yo
yo i'm gonna tell you right now i went
to philly
i i thought philly was the cleanest city
i've ever seen i came from new york
whatever oh my god
uh shout out to the bed and breakfast
but i met alan iverson
and i'm like wow this dude is almost my
height this is kind of crazy because on
tv he's small as hell yeah
yeah
and then to to meet your idol right
there but
to quickly uh talk about your mentality
with the shell casting
he was doing shout casting a long time
ago yeah anytime you had your basketball
and you was outside and you were
dribbling and you was taking your shot
you're like
sick mcnasty he's making a crossover he
crossed
you always so you were doing that then
and then i'm pretty sure when you were
playing your games and let's say it was
your time to sit in the back while
everybody else was playing you was
eating your snack or whatever you was
talking over their games then mm-hmm
it's the stuff that you've been doing
you accumulated
yeah mic in your face and you of course
we already know that you're fearless
there was right now i'm working with nba
teams that like this is a dream right i
got 76ers i worked with the charlotte
hornets the sacramento kings the golden
state warriors right and it was really
cool because i'm building these
connections with nba 2k league teams
with reputatives that represent the nba
and esports my dream these are my two
passions coming to the life video games
and basketball facts
being able to narrate something like
that
i i think you need even more flowers
because
like i've seen like i used to do with
like little stuff you have to know that
game in and out like because like
even if you're entertaining if you if
you could keep engagement pretty highly
sophisticated like especially when
you're doing like these games with these
hardcore audiences yeah they don't care
how entertaining you are if you don't
know their game they're going to get you
up out of there yeah yeah
yeah and especially with 2k they had a
lot of archetypes right you'd start to
look at building my player builds and
stuff like yeah there's a lot to know
there lots of balance and so
with them
and i got really close with the golden
state warriors because of my location of
my skill sets right and i got to host
the first ever uh warriors 2k tournament
live in person they drove me down there
put me up in a hotel and we went to 2k
headquarters and like had 10 kids who
were about to live out their dreams live
in front of me right like these 10 kids
worked very hard to get here to san
francisco they were battling for a draft
eligible spot in the 2k league right and
like there i am i get to bring a voice a
life to their big tournament right and
so
yeah shout casting has always been at
the forefront and doing 2k was really
special and then evolving that right
we'd bring up twitchcon again why aren't
you doing it now and i looked at my
friends i said let's host our own
tournaments right and so every sunday i
started to host my own tournament on my
twitch account whether it be smash bros
dragon ball z fighters whether it be
halo right and
i will always say on the podcast and
i'll always say to anyone it's 2021 and
i expect a lot out of video games what i
expect the most out of multiplayer
shooters in particular is full cross
play yes cross progression yes i expect
a good suite of custom games and i'm
looking for spectate mode that is what
halo infinite has done they have
launched with a custom game mode that
actually works and you can get people
into and it has a spectate mode and it
is really special to me who is
passionate about shout casting now where
me and my friends can now spectate and
outcast these things right and so i take
everything i've learned from that i take
everything i've learned from kind of
funny from the production side with
kevin and barrett of like this is what
vmix is this is how we bring in multiple
feeds right and now i look at my buddies
and i go well vmix costs 60 right i'll
buy that one of you will produce it two
of you will observe and i'll shoutcast
and that led into last week's tournament
where we hosted what what i consider is
a very professional brand tournament you
know right
yeah we put everything in place and we
did it and so yeah shout casting will
always be at the forefront and it's fun
to work for a company like kind of funny
who looks at you and goes anything you
want to do there's no dumb ideas let's
do it absolutely and they know i want to
shoutcast tournaments they know i want
to host events and they're right at the
forefront and they let me do all that
and so yeah i'm really really blessed
with the life i've got to live so far
because of all that tremendous man i
love the
just the multi-talented nature of what
you're doing and the flexibility and
being able to do these different things
absolutely
yeah yeah
i definitely want to ask you one other
question that i actually thought was
very interesting because i i've never
spoke to another gamer that kind of
likes what i like in this game me and
you share this passion for like active
sports and fitness games and like you
know saying like they're like how did
that start and like do you still get on
with that or cuz they're like where are
you at with that
always uh you know being a sports
fanatic like i am living the extreme
sports lifestyle up here i will always
gravitate towards extreme sports games
right you think of ssx tricky near and
dear to all of our hearts right do you
think of games like
1080 sean palmer's 1080 snowboarding i
think of amped i'm moving to sean white
i can name almost every snowboarding
game and skate game that's ever existed
i've played them all and i love them all
right and it's something where when you
truly live it right you come off the
basketball court you come off the
gridiron you play those games you love
it because you get to do things that you
could do or maybe you do right yes and
for me when we talk about skiing and
snowboarding games right like there you
are on the slopes you're doing it live
and then you come home and you get to
rip it up and you get to continue that
and so i'm really lucky to live in a
world where we have skate four coming
soon enough and yeah it might be a while
but like i'm excited for that i think of
games like shredders coming out this
february that i know phil is super
excited about and everybody should be
because this team is coming from amped
and it should be good writer's republic
which is a good game as well there's
some flaws to that but i am blessed to
be living in a world like that and it's
funny you bring that up i don't know
where it is oh but of course big shout
out to the connect right i was just
about to go there connect right i think
me and you would you doing xbox fitness
would you do it so nike plus fitness
russell wilson on it and i remember it
was the first time i ever booted it up
and i was like damn this is russell
wilson i'm about to show the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of wrestling right
now
let's go harder and i vomited right then
and then i walked outside and vomited
past that because of nike plus and so
give a big shout out to that one and
then
i
i
chased dear and williams around the golf
course because i wanted him to sign my
copy of nba baller beats which not many
people will ever know
nba baller beats his dance dance
revolution but with the basketball
and so
yes i don't even know about that one
love all of those active sports always
will save things
he was killing people that was the
advanced joy but i i was kind of
depressed yeah i was depressed when that
one went out because that was connect
too but connect one for me i remember
today is a ufc game
i think there was one ea no that
fighting game yeah it is yo
i'm sorry i listen i'm not gonna lie
i i don't i don't care the wii tricked
me into believing that there was one to
one cause i moved furniture out of the
way
play that wii sport they have boxing
and i don't care how rudimentary they
look i didn't care this is the first
time other than the arcades you had this
remember that stupid game in the arcade
that you can hold on to the um the
things metal hooks and you can turn it
it was really cumbersome but i was in
the fight i was i was breaking the
machine all right so now i'm in my
living room in my boxing shorts with my
controllers in my hand and i'm working
up such a sweat with this wii sports yes
until
my boy sits on the couch and no i was
not in my boxing show with your
boyfriend
with my nipples out that ain't happening
he sat on my couch
and did everything i did when i was
standing there like he was getting it
and what are you doing he just did this
again
and i'm like
he blew my mind and that's it he
shattered my reality but connect you
couldn't do that yeah i don't know
though
connect with exposure she had to get
your butt up there yeah
when they said get your heart rate up
yeah the full motion tracking all that
and then i remember there was one
particular game it was an ea active game
you had to put the wrist joint yes and
it had one your thing and it was
monitoring your heart rate and all right
check it out
but again salute the bike it's a
tremendous gaming history tremendous
journey brother
awesome it's a pleasure to hear these
type of stories i love that stuff you
guys are wild thanks for letting me
share this oh you already know man you
already know and of course i mean this
would be simple i mean clearly the
science behind the name it's colorado
the stone bite is it as simple as that
mike is it simple it's as simple as that
uh i was sick of wearing snowboard and
skiing boots i couldn't do it anymore we
went on craigslist in the dead middle of
summer and a kid was selling a snow bike
and it's literally a bmx bike with too
many snowboards for fifty dollars i
bought that shoved it in my dorm room it
took up a lot of space and people
thought i was insane and ten years later
i still ride it all the time people are
still blown away by what it is and uh
yeah it's been a ton of fun that was
where the name came from and uh the name
will stay for a while no doubt salute
that sp
you sure i'm sure
what's up
you sure can't be snow snowball no it's
not
we gotta ask you the question we asked
every guest in the room as per tradition
i need lord snow bike bikes top 5 video
games or franchises of all time
up five great question right there but
we're gonna go with of course halo and
all of the memories that was built
around halo so thank you to halo and all
of the teams from bungie to 343 who have
continued on with master chief in this
incredible franchising series it is
truly something i will always love and
cherish then as i look forward i'll
bring out a fun one for you conker's bad
fur day bring in the mature
titles to the platformers here's another
one for you right king you bring up
mario you bring up banjo right all these
games i never played those
you're a young kid and that is a heavily
mature title in your face and you're
like wow i didn't know we were doing
that right
let me let me ask you a question mike
are you a fan of clockwork orange
you know what never seen it at all you
don't know about it you don't know about
the ultraviolet right so all right sorry
so what i'm going to tell you to do and
i'm going to give you you need to watch
that okay right
go watch clockwork orange
i'm a huge fan i have that movie on
every medium that i was able to get it
on from dvd to laserdisc to to to vhs
every
every medium
when conker's bad fur day starts off
with that beginning
and that's straight out of clockwork
orange
okay yeah it's classic it became a lot
of scenes in there
it's gonna hit different it's gonna hit
different for you but crazy gotta watch
that movie so wild british movies wow
one hundred percent a great movie great
game i love you oh number two
first talk is reference guys
bring conquers and then of course let's
go into sports really quick and just
give some love to all of those titles
right i think of the street series and
def jam will always be near and dear to
my heart and a big one ncaa football
that deserves to be back pay those kids
take care of those kids but truly and
honestly that should be back because
that was one of the greatest specimens
right yeah king trust me i know it's
gonna be something weird and dumb and
nobody's gonna be happy but dark that
was something truly and honestly one of
the best things ever right
and then of course as i continue moving
forward all the love to grand theft auto
i could play those games forward and
back and remember every side road
remember every mission remember every
girlfriend remember cj getting buff
right all the stores that is truly
something special that i'll never forget
tell me when you said that you know you
could work out with your dude you know i
had him lift the weights all day i
looked
like when you said gorilla versus the
bear i was like yeah
yeah
it's funny in the definitive edition
right because i'm somebody who has
played those games recently before this
dropped so i like i like know what it
looked like and it didn't look good just
so everybody knows right
this game looks good sure there's some
flaws but like looks way better than
what we were playing 15 years ago but
the funny part is like you buff out cj
in these new games and he's got a neck
bigger than you can believe he doesn't
look right and i'm like oh man i hate
this i can't be my cj no more
that's one of the things that i have
like a huge issue with the industry
right now like is i feel like people are
so
chasing we want that game to look good
we want we want that that lighting to
look good and i just feel like like no
one looks at the gameplay anymore like
yeah i feel like a lot of the industry
you know they they want to spice up
we're going to make the game look really
good but there's no substance behind
anything about the game
what were you saying something no no you
got you
looking straight at you i thought you
made some calms
you're good you're good
okay you talking about games
yeah because that's why i was bringing
up like
like the nemesis system from the shadow
board or shadow of war like i feel like
the reason we haven't seen more like
more systems and more engines and
features like that is because you know
it's easier to sell you a nice looking
game than nice looking features
and that that's one of the things like i
really wish the industry would correct a
little bit
features is a spreadsheet graphics is
immediate yeah no no i know it's it's e
like you know look at e3 like there's a
reason that they they show you the best
at the e3 trailer
they're not trying to sell you a game
they're trying to sell you a vision
yes no i agree let's get that last one
and then the tough one is last one you
know i'd love to give a lot of love to
the elder scrolls franchise but when i
look back on him one that i
gotta give a big shout out to is
titanfall oh thank you titanfall for
releasing
and bringing some fresh blood
person shooter world that had been
around for a long time i still have my
big titanfall statue behind me
but truly and honestly yeah this game
when that released right that was one of
the first that was multi-player only and
maybe you didn't truly know that yeah
and that's one of those of like man this
is multiplayer only there's these weird
bots in there
at all yeah little guy in the back did
your little guy start leaning already
because that little peg is made out of
pvc he's leaning yeah yeah yeah
he's laying on his foot yeah
he was sideways on that on titanfall was
the atlas the ogre
and the ronin wasn't it like i think
that was the three times
those seem good it's right so yeah i
think that was one where a lot of people
call for that and respawn has blown up
in you know recent years of like the
true talent that's over there right and
we might not ever get a titanfall again
but when you think back to that period
of titanfall one that came at an
incredible moment that brought in
something that was fresh that was new
that was fun that really saved xbox one
a little bit in the beginning
for a little bit
yeah that's my top five yeah no that's
what's up man crazy like i got a shout
out title four
was legendary the wall running you know
and then with two with the grab look i
just got into it with somebody i was
like yo don't forget because i don't
know halo if it is the wave right now
and rightfully so but i was like don't
forget that titanfall 2 graphics i guess
the reason i guess the reason i can't
give it
the grappling hook is because like the
grappling hook was good but i never felt
like it had real substance behind when
you actually grabbed something like i
always felt like the graphic was flimsy
and it didn't feel like it had your
weight you know what to say but when i
grab people on halo i know i got them oh
no no yeah it's an aggressive play style
it's to get over here get to them type
joy you know what i said well i mean but
you know
it was definitely a solid like i will
say without attic word
without titanfall in the in the way they
implied the grappling hook system and
stuff yeah there is an argument that you
could say that maybe halo wouldn't have
grabbed the wall running the in and out
the pilot it did a lot man but look
tremendous five and last one oh lord
mike okay
i just had a quick question do you you
didn't really play the fable games oh
here we go jim's trying to force his
game here he goes oh yeah
i need you to clarify something after
this addict but i'm glad you brought
that up sir uh i do enjoy the fable
games i i i can't put them in my top
five because when they ask me for the
top five it's tough but i will give a
lot of love to fable and the decision
making with something special i'll never
forget yes yeah i wouldn't try to like
put them in your top five i was just
curious
now now king's about to attack me over a
comment on youtube last week um so attic
um is this something that you need to
talk to me about sir
oh are you look just because i messed up
about it how to how to engage thunder in
a fight doesn't mean it doesn't still
look like you
oh okay
on the face
yeah i'm real messy mike yes yes time
i
favorite
i think i know the answer to this but
favorite console of all time for any
generation and why
i love the new consoles and where we're
at today and all the new features but
i'll always give love to the xbox 360.
it was just a perfect time in my life i
was i felt like i was and i am the
target demographic for that right that
would have been 14 years old that would
have been in my primitive years of like
hey we're coming at you with all these
games we want you to buy these and i did
everything right from the dongle to xbox
live to the upgrades right you think of
the original from the arcade and the
hard drive then you go on to the
different series
your faceplates yeah they they have me
that was me
you ever went to somebody for somebody
else and they had no faceplate
like yo yo why is your 360 naked
what's crazy i think people don't get
microsoft enough credit for this like
you take the you know the people who
had the foundation and the and the
structure they wanted xbox live to be
and you take them out of microsoft and
then they bring out the 360 not with
that kind of infrastructure on xbox live
with the original xbox and the 360.
i
i don't know if gaming would be where it
is right now like because looking
forward yeah
they pushed it drastically forward it
wasn't even a little bit like it was a
lot see well
you got to understand microsoft's dna
was always that connectivity all right
so they were going to push that into
their console to connect everybody to
link everybody together so they made
sure that they have i mean that was bill
gates's whole thing he was like the xbox
if they can't sell bill gates on the
xbox being yeah
being the computer in the in the in the
living room there's no xbox yeah that
story when you hear sheamus and those
guys talk about it and mike bach you
know it was true i cannot wait to get
seamus yeah yeah we got one day he's fun
ken you're gonna like him a lot he's
really cool we gotta put a filter on
sheamus but yeah yeah
you know what a lot of these dudes that
i think um that i call for because i
call for a lot of dudes that we need a
filter for um we're just gonna have to
do uh uh iron lords after dark
i don't care yeah you don't you don't
want a whole sheamus background
he wants
[Music]
i could get the poll and then you can um
there's only a few super chats okay okay
you want to get that okay
okay we got uh
yeah okay
i'm not gonna read this one let me let
everybody thank you rd
it was that crazy
wow okay
you guys look at it are you telling me
okay okay
then we got jeff grubb's game message we
read this one in the game five dollars
which i respect mike's time
i got that thanks jeff gloves absolute
grubby gravity and we got shroom kingdom
two dollars for a job remember nba
inside driving og x-box
inside yo you remember street heads
street hoops is
then we got kiss move we just mentioned
it right now five thousand chest
snowbike mike usually connects to get us
nba ballers nba street and nba street
i'm trying i'm trying every day
uh then you have we have you cannot
defeat my state in style five dollars
xbox making moves out here like stefan
diggs making sony fans look like
marshawn lattimore
really go in there
okay
then we got a shoe kingdom two dollars
shout out to the wood grain 360 face
plate that is the one that i bought
uh i was good with that
because i had i had a floor model tv i
was not going back
i ain't mad at that
that's it we're good
that's what's up so look man let's get
into this poll
i have a question mm-hmm right they
thought it was gonna be this
transformative thing they thought the
playstation wings was gonna be the first
place for the 360.
time or kids
two weeks ago
it's not last week's police two weeks
ago poland and the people have spoken
with the recent reports and leaks of
multiple xbox exclusives planned for the
future which title has you the most
excited to come to the xbox platform the
winner of a kind of razor close four-way
ilp poll at 36 percent of the vote
was the messy lords i don't care these
xbox leaks are undefeated
covered in at second place at a close 32
percent of the vote was compulsions
project midnight group
and third place at 20 of the vote was
microsoft's one versus 100 return and in
last place kind of respectable 12
percent of the vote was obsidian's
project pentamic group shout out to all
the lords who participated lord solve
man what you what you thinking about
this uh the people
saying that xbox got leaked problems
would this have been like the biggest
announcement ever if it hadn't leaked
yes yes
yes bananas you know but whatever is
done what's done is done i think that
one versus 100 coming back yeah uh for
the way listen
xbox right now in terms of online and
stuff like that it really has elevated
what we expect from an online service
and ecosystem it really has so if one
work versus 100 comes back the way it's
supposed to do
it can really really really hit big time
and i i wish they had brought it back
kind of when we were in the midst of the
pandemic really because out of it
tune in on every day
a specific time frame yeah yeah that
would have been crazy um but i think i'm
excited to see what they do with that
yeah no doubt no doubt and uh looks like
shout out to hustle and motivate 2000
chances shout out to mike in the nba
streets volume two love
okay boys we see that we see you hustle
but we gonna get into these topics so
look y'all y'all know what it is this uh
halo infinite is out bad you know it
says so a lot going on you know there's
a lot of controversy in regards to the
progression system
and the um i believe the live event
fracture tenri event so we want to get
into that man so let's start i'm gonna
start with you lord mike as far as like
what do you feel first about you know
let's start with the good
what do you feel about you know the
gameplay and then obviously then the bad
news what are you what are you feeling
about people's frustration with the
progression and maybe the monetization
aspects
yeah let's talk about the good i mean
the game is good it runs very well it
plays very well the team over at 343 has
nailed multiplayer and you know give
them some love multiplayer has been
always good over with their game
development teams there's no question
about that it's been the campaign but
they have brought it and i think it was
really exciting of course to drop that
on the 20th anniversary to get the
energy and the excitement going right as
uh king has said it's still a beta so
we'll talk about that but as of right
now the positives are the game is
awesome and fun to play and it's
exciting and it works and it's awesome
to get 12 of your friends in a lobby to
do big team and that just works or it's
fun to get 24 of your friends and play
custom games right so when i look at the
positives the list goes on and on and i
think that's why you hear such a big
outcry right now is because the game is
good and people are excited to play it
and they want to play it and now we live
in a world where it's not 2006 where you
just play the game and that's kind of it
now players want to be rewarded for
their time they want to earn things
right we live in a world with micro
transactions and battle passes right and
there's a lot that goes into it and of
course you guys know and myself and the
team over at the x cast knew when we
came into this there was talk about
battle passes and this team wanted to
put on a different kind of spin a
different touch to it right and they
wanted to do it their way they were
going to listen to the community and of
course adjust as we're going to see
right now but they wanted to change that
formula up and that formula has been
kind of driven into the ground and i'll
call it perfected right with fortnite
call of duty apex all these games where
you're rewarded for the games that you
play the kind of style that you play
there's challenges on the side for extra
xp but that is the normal to all of us
right we get that we want that we like
that and now when you jump into it and
you see what halo has done and you walk
out of a game and you've gone 27 and
five just like attic has gone right and
he goes why do i only get 50 xp for this
i'm not happy about it
there's an issue right you know what's
the worst
snow bike like yesterday or the day
before i went like something crazy it
was like 35 and four or something like
that and i'm sitting there didn't hit me
until someone on my team said it i'm
sitting there they're like my attic you
went crazy he's like yeah and then they
they said the most
damned thing i ever heard it it ended up
being like and it's a shame that uh that
that uh that zero and 22 uh at the other
team got the same amount of points that
you did oh my god
did you see the meme there's a meme on
twitter right now where they got a
person is like i went you know um it's
the top of the leaderboard 20 kills
capture the flag win the match and then
it said 50 xp and then they got a person
over with the cartoons like yeah i got
50 xp and i didn't do any of the
objectives and all i did was four random
weapon kills i got the same xp is that
dude continue i had to get the ball off
because that was hilarious but continue
mike that was crazy
and so that's the conversation we're
having right now and i will give some
credit to the team for being quick right
you release this game during a holiday
break we want everybody to get their due
time off and time with their families to
relax but also you have an outcry of
like hey this game is really good and
we're not pleased with how this battle
pass is implemented right and of course
if you had been keeping up you knew this
was how it was going to go and we had
questions going in but i think the
switch to only challenges has been a big
negative right as you all have
experienced and i've experienced right
i've played 45 hours of this game and in
all honesty i've probably earned five to
seven levels right and that is because
i am not keeping up with the challenges
that's not how i play i want to play to
win or i want to play my own but mike
let me ask a question though who fault
is that
exactly so that's on me right there
there's a weird balance that's on me
because i knew what they wanted to do i
should have been doing that but also i'm
not gonna a perfect example for you king
last night i'm doing the fracture
challenges right right and my challenge
now is to get 20 assists and now do i
play my normal game and get whatever
assists i get or do i focus on that and
so now king i'm running around as the
anchor
i'm shooting them twice and i'm going
okay you kill him
are you gonna help me
you gotta kill him bro i need you right
now i need you you know you know what's
funny uh mike what we was sitting there
kid smoothie did that maybe you sit
there and you know you you keep doing
this over and over again and then you'll
know you'll get like high assists but
the moment that game tells you you need
assist you ain't getting no assistance
focus on it
i'm sitting there playing this game like
okay here's my issue what the what the
the challenge is like
i when i saw you could ask everyone on
this day i'm like they're gonna have
issues because it's the same stuff i
don't like on destiny where they're
making people play with stuff they don't
want to play with and you're having
unbalanced teams because half the team's
doing the challenges half the team's
doing bounties and they're not playing
the game and it's like you're you i
don't want to don't make me play with
some whack covenant pistol nobody want
to do that don't make me like look
sure maybe triple and overkills anything
above a triple kill might be a little
bit too much but keep the challenges
focused on stuff like that playing games
getting maybe one killing spree getting
like three or four double kills like
something you can easily get with just a
rocket launcher you know what i'm saying
no don't make me kill
20 get 20 assists and then there was
like i'm right now i'm doing one on
fiesta that's like i got to get five
killing
sprees that's right
i'm sitting here like i played six games
and i'll get to like four and i'm about
to get that fifth kill and i get
rocketed
here like like that's where i i have a
whole and then
and then the biggest issue i have too is
like just a good laugh
they will have challenges based on modes
that you can't get into
you know like you know
stronghold i'm like okay
they can hear this yeah they can keep
this but what they need to do is imply a
voting system to give people the option
to go into something sure you might not
have a chance to do it but you play one
game and the next one what they should
do is the first one's a map then the
second one's the mode like that's what
they need to do because like i have too
many people just leave it off the bat
and i get a 3 4 the moment i see 3 4 3
on my name i have a vein on my forehead
i'm like oh so that dude wanted
stronghold but we had oddball so like
but at the end of the day i can't blame
them because it's like if they're trying
to get those challenges what let's be
real here this is exactly how 343
originally intended on getting these
levels up is through these challenges
who over there thought that was it
i don't care like
see because this is called a beta they
knew what they was doing so they said
you really want jump levels pay that
forty four dollars and you know what my
wallet said god bless say less
the thing is though is i i don't think
this is go like they might say beta
but i think there's multiple reasons
that they said i think one they because
they promised in marketing over and over
again these are coming out the same time
right i don't think that i think this
we might get swapped for a new mode or
something but i think this is the game
that's what i want to bring i'm
comfortable with where i'm at though
like i hear all the people talking oh my
progression is too slow if you play it
how they asked you to yeah
no but no he he's got a point there like
look like i will say
that their system is flawed for a lot of
reason big time but i but i'm almost
level 50 and it's a week and a half in
see wow
you could easily get through that 100
how did you get to the level 50 what did
you do
no no you you get the first 25 but he
could first play five
the thing is is they never the the
amount of xp it gets to level up never
increases it's always a thousand
the challenge is 200 to 300 to 400 of
that amount of space right i do think
that you need to be rewarded if you
excel and if you win a game yeah period
i agree but at the same time
look i'm saying that this system is
flawed right but i can understand why
they thought it would work
it's just i felt like some of the
implying that they should have put onto
it doesn't make sense by making certain
game modes that you can't get into by
going into something where it's
randomized and you you literally we
played big team battle for an hour and a
half and it took cog an hour and a half
to get strongholds yeah i had no control
over that and that that that's an issue
because now you're having people leave
because they want strongholds shut up
sit there please shut up your engagement
so we know what bounties you do have and
we not gonna give you that until like
the fifth time so you can be rewarded
for sticking around you get what you
want if you stay there long enough and i
don't care about all the people crying
oh hello he's not giving me strength
it's ridiculous it's not the thing is
though it's not about crying it's about
constructive
criticism constructive criticism means
that i could see how they see that
progression system could have worked but
at this because like if i could get to
to level 50 even though i skipped 25
that's 25 levels in a week
of challenges
you can easily get into you can easily
get all work dedication
i'm agreeing with you 100
but my thing is like you're making
everyone laugh i can't get any point
across because i was laughing over me
what's yours
get you get your bars off sir put your
bars nobody get your buzzers all i'm
saying is i could see their vision it
was just cr it wasn't correctly implied
like right i felt like just little
things like
if you would have put you know voting
system to where people could have voted
on the next map you could have had a
better chance because you felt like you
had more control of what kind of mode
you're going to play in if you i do
think that you need to stay away from
you know
weapon challenges because i think
forcing players to play with certain
weapons is going to unbalance the team
because if you make me play with the
pistol that weekly challenge isn't
getting done
like the the the the covenant pistol the
plasma pistol i'm not doing that it's
over this is where me and you are
diametrically opposed to that
all right because at the same time when
i know i and they have a swap button
they do have a swap there's a swap
button you don't like that bounty swap
it out right so okay that that
automatically eliminates that now the of
the thing that you was asking so let me
ask you a question real quick let me let
me address that all right how do you get
those swap features there king i paid
for that just like you
that's like you
you know what my son said
because my son doesn't have the swap
feature he said i can only swap out one
a week or something like i said ah man
you don't work either
the thing is though the thing is is
regardless if you could swap stuff
it is ridiculous the fact that they give
they they put your team in situations
where instead of playing the game
exactly right i'm playing alone
but the thing is instead of playing the
game they are putting some of your
teammates in positions like they might
have to go out of their way to get a
weapon that they don't normally use
which is automatically going to put you
at a disadvantage and on top of the
disadvantage what are they going to do
like they do on destiny they're going to
camp the heavy they're going to camp the
spawn so you got people now
i love all of this like just the whole
thing
listen literally i'm breaking the game
breaking the game
my money
you don't play my channel if i tell me
you don't play my channel
in my ignorance
i sat there playing fiesta mode hard
body right yeah not knowing that those
bounties are supposed to be up because i
was trying to get that little samurai
armor i needed it because i spent my
money and why can't i have this right
because you're mad right now right i
cannot get this and you can't go buy it
because you need to have the core right
right so if you don't have the core you
out there just flinging cash all over
the place
you got to go earn that right so okay
this is where my earning came in i'm mad
as hell right so i'm like i ain't got
this call and i'm seeing people running
around with this armor i am so upset
because i spent my money and i know he
didn't
yo
yo how did he get in the club
[Laughter]
situation
he won't pass
get 25 assists
oh i got the pistol that you don't like
see i'm running past people taking the
shield off i will and my man
i do want to vocally say
that we come from the destiny background
well we're used to doing boundaries i
don't care about nobody else this is my
44
but no but see that that so what's funny
is you guys say in addict's world
for the girls
at the end of the day we're used to
doing these type of batteries we're used
to grinding these
milestones
and i get that and like you know i don't
even think the battle pass is the issue
i think the progression is the issue and
that's making the battle pass
to get the 25 levels i think that's the
problem
when they saw you jumping the party oh
god and you all started all off at level
one but your credit card had a different
balance than that
but the thing is though king is you
don't even see what other people's
battle pass level is so that doesn't
even make sense you know you know why so
so when i told them oh my god i just
jumped to x-men how did you do that oh i
paid for it and i got no problem with
saying i did this like
i i do think for the most part it is
pretty solid right but no
they've made a lot of money clearly look
if you get my i rarely buy micro
transactions rarely i bought twice two
of them so like like and then you got
people like blaze spending like 250 300
on it so like mike how much money you
spent i'm 150 and so i'm like you
kidding me
just so you know i'm level 77 on my
battle pass oh my god
i only heard seven levels so you know
what happened there okay you know what
happened
can't smooth spit spend a hundred on
like look at the end of the day i do
think that it needs a little bit of fine
tweaking that needs to be more like do
it there needs to be more like weekly
challenges to get certain cosmetic
things and i think that what what they
could do that would actually do really
good is like imply the master chief
collection to where if you do certain
things on there weekly over there it
carries over to infinite for something
from the master chief collection kind of
like kind of work them together but like
i got killed your ips is very high i got
to cover y'all because you know what
crazy
get his balls off
i gotta ask mike a question so please
okay i just want to ask one question yes
right
all the individuals are set for
sovereignty and i don't know about you i
don't know about you
i don't know about you yet because i'm
going to ask you in a second yes but all
of us here so far i know three of us
here
have financially invested in something
that was a free beta yes right yeah yeah
have they not been successful
so just because we gave them money don't
don't mean they can't get this smoke now
that i don't know how swiss works
i'm gonna give them my bars regardless
how you feel and how much money you've
invested
this is true all right look we gotta
open i didn't ask mike a question before
y'all went off on the red which was uh
yeah i totally took the joint but um
look the question that y'all say a lot
is beta
right we keep saying beta beta so the
question i have for mike and then we'll
get it to solve his thoughts and stuff
is that like
do we consider this a beta is this
because a lot of people was like hey you
can't review this you know it shouldn't
be reviewed because technically it's a
beta do we think
it is fair to put this criticism on it
yet or it's like hey you charge money
you get the smoke you know kind of thing
so where are you at with that mike like
when the whole beta controversy because
you can't criticize it or you can't
criticize it
you know that that's a tough one there
cog when you talk about beta and where
we're at today and you look at other
betas that have dropped right but truly
honestly i do expect them to open up a
little bit when we get to december 8th
with playlists right they have announced
that this is the full maps right these
are 10 maps that you're gonna get so i
don't expect brand new maps on december
8th okay whether i want them or not
right but i do expect a little bit of
opening when it comes down to playlists
and stuff but should i be able to
give them back some constructive
criticism and have a conversation or
even review it like ign has yeah totally
i think this is going to be
very close to your full product that
you're going to get when they announce
that it's not a beta right on december
8th if that's what's up so i think
you're getting very close to what they
expect you to get so yeah for me no i
think it's all i think they need the
feedback too this team knows that they
wanted to change it up and there's a lot
of feedback out there no doubt and that
that that's the reason i'm so vocal snow
bike is like this is the most fun i've
had in a multi-player but it's a halo
game and years and i want this game to
come out there next holiday it's
smackdown warzone in fortnight so like
like in in the survival of this game it
does have to compete with the other for
free to play games so it's like if you
don't like they're trying to do what
fortnite does the exact thing almost
because this is about what fortnite does
but the problem is is fortnite has a lot
more reach that halo can't realistically
get for halo can't do
a a live concert most promo i hope i
would hope they wouldn't do that like so
like they don't have that reach to the
casual market that halo does so halo's
got to do stuff differently than
fortnight does right no we get that we
get i got to get solvents so what are
your thoughts man about you know just
the multiplayer you know the good
obviously how you feeling by and then
obviously the controversy in reference
to the progression and the alignment
they're all just a bunch of crackheads
yeah yeah yeah i really can't help
yourselves i really can't you can't
oh
i saw this from the beginning right and
i'm just like no i'm here to play halo
you're here to be ashy again dip me in
ash i don't care
let make me look like i'm running around
dipped in concrete i don't care i
i don't until i do let me let me know
that's what you're doing
listen balancing a free-to-play game is
is no easy task right so they've done a
really good job coming out the gate too
right right so just remember besides the
spike gun that needs to get nerfed
there's no reason you should do one hit
to kill anything this is a conversation
that's going to be happening for years
because they're just going to keep
tweaking and balancing right so
you're going to go through your ups and
downs like you guys go through hey with
destiny where you hate it for a little
while you love it for a little while
this is this is the cadence this is what
it is right so
i can understand everybody's beast
particularly what i see with the battle
pass now right what i see like yes like
again i i play a match whatever and i
get my little 50 at the end and i'm like
wow and i'm at zero and you see
the long line to get to the one i'm like
oh man
now the thing is at my at my core i
don't care about that right right i
really don't care about it's just funny
to see right
so
one thing that adam adam mentioned that
is very true that i do believe because
now they are playing in this space right
it's imperative that they fix this
sooner rather than
yes because despite me just being there
for halo and that part of halo being
great right
if they don't fix this
then at the end of the day what you're
going to have is just hardcore halo guys
playing this game and it's not going to
have the reach you intended for it to
have as a free-to-play game right if
they and because a lot of the younger
players the players that are used to
playing the fortnights the war zones
fortnite has had years to figure this
out right warzone st also has had time
to figure this out right if they don't
figure this out quickly
gamers are fickle yeah they're gonna i
don't wanna walk away from them
the thing except the hardcore yeah the
thing is like when it comes to like the
progression they need a final better way
of rewarding you know people that play
above average they need to find a better
way of rewarding cosmetics to certain
people so i said like imply the master
chief collection to do certain things to
get certain things over on infinite i
think that would be good like all i need
to see is people like dr disrespect talk
all that incense and then when that game
come out he dropped all that and you
could see the genuine joy in him playing
the game so like you can talk all you
want but when you play those sticks and
you play that game all that's out the
way
and that's the thing right the game is
there so yeah it would be sad it would
be sad if people walk away from it just
because this part isn't working a whole
bunch of hub up for nothing okay
i think on december 8th when the game
actually launches everything will be
transformed i think oh you think it's a
major change what happened
what do you think is transforming
between
um
i believe that the single player is
going to give you a lot of that xp that
you're looking for i agree i agree with
that
challenges okay if you look in the
challenges it you see a lot of
incidences where it says npvp so there's
a they're designated
yeah so um i i i believe that stuff is
tied there so i believe everybody's have
this this this fake outrage but still
out there blazing it to their knuckle
because they don't want to spend the 44
50. so they have to pay 44.50 to enjoy
this game you know and the whole thing
is then suffer and grind that's it
suffer and grind or pay your 44 and get
up there right so
just declaring king you pay your 44 and
they're still asking you to grind
because yeah
you can't get them you can't get the
digit
until
you agree
that
people should only get 50 experience
regardless if they win or lose that's
acceptable that's good we can i don't
care about their pain
like you see what you're wilding out
about is i'm doing the challenge i
learned
this is this is the same person that
said so i got my name yo you know you
know what's about to happen here
i can i have a crystal ball i can see
the future
at one point in time
i don't know if it's gonna happen in
this episode maybe in the future king's
gonna say well add i've saved so much
money from game pass i can afford to
give halo infinite my money no no this
is see it's not even that it's about me
being a hypocrite
that's right shout out to me identifying
me all right
so i sat here and i went in on all you
dudes about that baby boy yes and you
out here and
[Music]
about oh i don't like micro transactions
that's your wallet talking that's
i don't have that problem like i think
loot boxes should be out of st i don't
care about that i'm going to pay
every every uh
corporation's dream you know and you
know
this is what we have to clarify now
king king
just this just remember anytime anything
like this comes up they're gonna say we
we know we know that if it gives you an
unfair advantage that's right king is
there
when it came listen he looked normally
we'd be in breath of the wild like why
would you cheat in brethren
i mean we've been having fun and talking
about it we haven't even talked about
the new event and the battle pass there
right and we look at that's another 30
levels and there's a whole another beast
but here's one for y'all that maybe you
didn't see right let's go if you look at
the battle pass near and close oh yeah
there's 16
whether it be missions or challenge
swaps and xp boots that's half of your
battle pass it's not even it's not even
any sort of cool costume
then when you break it down past that
five of those are just weapon stickers
and get this there's not a single cool
samurai
that content is not there right if
you're gonna give us the cool samurai
armor i love that but at least give me
some cool skins before i have to go drop
twenty dollars yeah i don't know which
one you're like
i'll drop you know what it is
what they have to figure out about the
free to play thing
is that and i don't play these games but
what they got to figure out what they
can get away with that's what they got
yeah but the thing is
they'll do that eventually trust me
but
up front
when you drop these games right up front
you have to make the player feel
[Music]
we would be paying for everything
you know you know the pay to win market
that left that stuff would still be what
this is the thing though if they start
figuring this out and getting it right
the majority of the people playing the
game will be what you
think they need to do is get it right so
that they trust me they're working on it
let me let me give you okay i'm sorry i
gotta get my balls off the bike yeah
okay i was gonna say i'm coming from
you're looking at a guy who plays a lot
of battle royales and first person
shooters right i've played years of war
zone and fortnight and i'm similar to
king now where battle passes i don't
really engage with unless i really see
something i like i just go to the store
and buy it right i'm like ariana grande
you want it you buy it you got it right
and so for me now a big shout out is the
hcs store supporting the esports
right and what i really love is like
shout out to the space station
that's really cool that also supports
the devs but it supports the esports
initiative right a portion of that
that buy goes into the pot where people
can play just like dota does with a lot
of things yeah you know what snowbite i
wonder if those teams are sitting there
looking and was like who got your colors
on nobody no it is it is i wanna i can't
solve it i gotta get my boss off after
you so so mike real quick as somebody
who plays those type of games and has
played them from their inception like
you know when fortnite first came out
with it what is it that draws you in
from the beginning apart from the
gameplay right
is it the fact that they give you a
bunch of stuff up front to sort of draw
you in and then as the game progresses
it levels it out because i feel like
halo what they're doing right now is it
feels like you're in the middle of year
two or three where the progression is
sort of leveled off instead of hey
this game is a month old we just threw
it out there just go here's all this
cool stuff bring you in make you want to
spend the money yeah because you think
that's what that's the cadence of that
you're going to be receiving stuff and
then all of a sudden it kind of levels
off yes obviously it's so well it's like
you can tell they look at the market now
and they're like we got to be that right
right what i really love about fortnite
and i don't play it much that often now
but like whenever i do jump back in you
know what feels good is when i jump in
and i level up that battle pass from
like one to level 10 within an hour or
two of playing and it's like oh i'm
being rewarded for my time and my
efforts here and it's fun and it's
exciting and sure half the stuff on the
battle pass i'll never use or like but
it does feel like you're being rewarded
and that's the issue right now with halo
is where people just want to feel that
incentive they want to chase that carrot
yeah and it's not quite there right
they've really doubled down on the
transactions and cog i want you to speak
but there's one thing you know i give a
lot of credit call of duty you know
we'll talk about activision on a
different world different podcasts but
like they do a good job but they figured
out their storefront that is 15 to 20
for a bundle and it has a lot of stuff
in there the halo bundle right now if
you look at some of those we're talking
about a stance we're talking they just
tried to sell me a warthog windshield
just so everybody knows it's a
windshield to go on a warthog yes that's
not a color that's just a black warthog
windshield and so they have an issue
there in the storefront where i gave
credit to the hcs skins the bundles
right now it feels like you get one cool
thing and then five things that are
tacked on that are just awful and it's
like man that's 20 to 15 down the drain
that you should not be buying yeah it's
crazy let's let's get into this at the
end of the day like let's start with the
good obviously
the kick is back let's just call it for
what it is you know what i'm saying as
far as
the best competitive pvp the most fun
sandbox
you know the ranking system and pvp you
know that us as destiny players been you
know really wanting we've said this on
the last word podcast shout out to thai
guy travers from ign you know that we've
been saying like yo if destiny had a
true ranking and progression you know to
separate the layers you know the servers
for the most part solid you know they
really from a live service standpoint
they hit the ground running amazing
stealth drop xbox 20. the hype is in the
building big team battles the most fun
chaotic romp i've done in years just
people in and out of my party yes it's
it's it's next level epitome of fun so
let's just get that out that's why i
guess
everyone's going at it a little hard
because it's like
gay i got it let me say something real
quick yes
at the end of the day
regardless what they messed up they
messed up the stuff that's easily fixed
mess up the
eggs
all this the good part is all this is
fixable because at the end of the day
that the actual core gameplay is what
matters and what i'm gonna say i'm not
gonna give him a complete pass but what
i will say is that because i believe
shout out to joseph state and he him he
had a great interview with ryan
mccaffrey on unfiltered and they talk
about kind of just like when he jumped
on you know landing the plane and making
sure what's important gets done first so
sadly you know we lost forge we lost
co-op campaign you know as a result but
i do agree with the overall sentiment
that if the core gameplay ain't fun
then they don't matter what the
transition's up now but let's
get to the smoke down look yo i've been
i've been doing this live service thing
for a minute man hey look i'm i'm like
king if i want something i will buy it
you know what i'm saying i'm not gonna
sit here fraud and act like i will spend
money if i like something but what it is
is what mike's there's nothing for cog
at the beginning of a season on destiny
yeah they got me they got they sold they
just samurais
this was all me they was like we gonna
test what your wallet could do because
we know about you
yeah we know go see all that you know
but we know what you about the problem
though is i got what mike said if you
look at the fracture event and you look
at these battle passes right and you
look at the actual content right
it is majority xp and challenge skips
right then they got the nerve to be like
yo we're gonna give you a level three
we're gonna give you the right shoulder
pad then we go
show the pad why are you splitting up
the shoulder pads fan so you just showed
me you ain't got a lot of content
individuals
you might have a spiked shoulder pad
here
give me the complete shoulder pads and
stop trying to
i think the issue is king
is the hot shit's in the store yes but
they are filling half the actual past
feature thing
with xp and separating separation
because they don't and here's the thing
but here's where it really is egregious
right
right the part is
the it's all right we play destiny we
play these other
no no this is games
if you get
a color unlocked right i should be able
to use the color blue they said no
everything i want to use it on my suits
i want to use it on the go why are they
limiting the blue yo there's this one
droid i bought it to take monetize right
yeah yeah shout out to you corbin kid
like bro they got a blue pack that comes
they got because they got a ninja sword
as an ornament right i mean a ninja star
as an ornament on any weapon that you
can put on any weapons there's a lot to
that part but then they got the blue
that is locked to the assault rifle so
only by assault rifle guy have this blue
that's it no other gun hydra
that is ridiculous right so
you got
if they continue this because one thing
about game play is if they don't feel
their time is respected if they don't
feel that their investment is there they
are out and here's the thing i don't
want that to happen to this game so it
is imperative to this game here's the
key and attic is going to understand
this it is imperative for this game
whoever their live team is because let's
be real the team's already split up
there's going to be another team they're
working on season two of this season
three of the dance the campaign live
service all that right
whoever's on the day-to-day lives if
they're not agile and fast enough to
react or if they choose not to listen
there's going to be major problems this
thing the player base will die
regardless the fleet of play so it is
imperative that they get it because it's
not going to be a whole bunch of king
davids running around with 45 dollars to
spend every five minutes and thinking
that's their game play okay let me put
it to you this way
then fixing the issues is the difference
between them being a very contender next
year right and then being the hardest
game on the market next year yeah that's
it and the last thing i'll say like i
said you know like mike said playlist a
lot of stuff is easily fixable you know
playlists specific stuff you know a
little bit more on the cross play um
being out of out of casual stuff you
know they got and ranked where you can
you can play against controller guys but
you shouldn't have forced cross play in
casual if you don't want to they could
they could do that and then yeah like
alex said the vote system on the maps
making sure like hey i've got bro i got
oddball four times i would love to do
slayer you know like that just those
basic things but that's pretty much it
man i mean at the end of the day the
game is fun these things can be
corrected and as far as the beta the
last thing i'll just say is that look at
the other day if you are charging money
people got the right to complain and
criticize you know a constructive
constructive criticism about your your
product so that's guess king get your
hands up i see it let me get out of here
thank you because i didn't want to
interrupt yes thank you yes yes please
i wanted i wanted to interject yes um we
have to go oh so called interrupt
interrupt
no no i said i love messing with you
come on man i'm taking my joy this is my
sunday yeah he wanted to push your butt
continue no but nah i love when we
attack anyway um
the reviews
on the call of duty and the battlefield
i think that dictated their agility
when they was like oh we're the hottest
girl on the block we ain't gotta worry
about it
come back after the holidays come back
after that
so now that they controlling this
situation and they didn't know that they
would be in this position like this
lined up perfect for them yes they their
biggest worry was call of duty yeah
their biggest worry was maybe
battlefield gets it right
when you see that it didn't get it right
or these are they are stutter stepping
and you are ascending you're the new kid
on the block and you're free to play
yeah
per se new kid on the block because this
is a different generation that is
actually experiencing halo not us old
heads that understand it and have
experienced it
but it's a new flavor of the week
so in doing this
they don't have to switch up anything
and this is why i say i don't believe
that they will but i also believe on
december 8th you will see a difference
in how the xp is pd out and then
everybody's going to be like oh wow it
did tie into this and they do that yeah
that that'll be huge but but i say this
king again going back to how fickle some
players can be especially with this
free-to-play stuff
when
december 8th might be too late for
something it's never stopped you all day
but some players for some players
but
in king's defense off there's really
nothing
out there to take you away from it okay
they have one more hurt
one more hurdle and that is the new
uh war zone map oh yeah i don't know
he's right
was all right you you are very right
they've conquered the first two hurdles
but they have one big hurdle which is
when that hits that will bring a lot of
players back over there so yes i think
december 8th will be a big moment and i
think playlist will be the leading
factor in that but yeah they have one
big hurdle left and
war zone's going to be it will be the
big one i agree the thing is is they've
defeated the monetary games they haven't
even fought the free to play games
fortnite hasn't dropped anything yet
warzone's about to like they've defeated
the people that you have to go and spend
60 70 to play yeah no facts facts they
it's just that that the other ftp
yeah let's go but um mike i got to
respect until i see it because i know we
got to crown your little segment how you
doing i just want to make sure you're
okay i'm feeling good looking good i got
my game awards nomination ballots up in
front of me so we can know okay
let's just go right into it
yeah addict's time is limited
you want to scare your screen and then
we could just breathe through just the
game award stuff and get that popping
and then we'll get the super chats after
because i know i gotta respect addict's
time because i know he has to leave
right after that
and then okay that joint going alex we
need the link yeah yeah all right
so he's sharing he's sharing his
pictures yeah he's got no he's sharing
the thing so we could all see the um the
category okay because i got it in front
of me okay okay and then you do you do
the tally like how we do uh with crown
your lord yeah i just tally afterwards
yeah so again no esport individual
awards we'll be doing we'll just start
from like what most anticipated
yeah they're the only the only reason we
don't do this yeah the only reason we
don't like do like the esports like and
death is because we don't know a lot of
the esports and realm we will get your
super chats at this but i have to
respect addict's time on this all right
so best esports game is what we're
starting at yeah yeah yeah it is
call of duty
counter strike global offensive dota 2
league of legends and valorem all right
let's start with usb and apparently it's
sponsored by group
coming away with best esports game
you know when i break it down guys this
is a an awesome category with a lot of
heavy hitters right here i think you see
the three old school the vets will call
them league of legends dota 2 and
counter strike all are always in the
competition always a conversation of a
lot of incredible things that they do
call of duty coming hot off of the cdl
and that has had a really strong couple
of years now i do look at valorant
though valerian will be esports game of
the year this has made a huge splash in
the esports community people love
watching the uh different series that
they host and this has really taken over
so valorance i think this year has made
a major impact on the esports world lord
attic what you got that's esports game
man call of duty ain't one in there
uh counter strike i think that could go
to it but i got i gotta agree with snow
bike like valor has literally changed
the entire industry in terms of how that
scene has worked it's kind of like a
mixture
because i've never played valid because
it's only on pc and i don't play with
the pc people like that but um
it's kind of like a mixture what i've
been told of like overwatch and counter
strike like it's got like classes and
that's pretty much the best way i've
been described i think if howard's gonna
get it i really do i'd be very surprised
but but to you guys to the rest of the
lords i think call of duty's one in this
so you guys should vote that i'm just
what you doing
yeah it's valerian hands down like right
if y'all see everything that riot is is
dropping like the fighting game and
everything
everything is really quality like and
valerian i've heard nothing but great
things about balance so i think this is
the year okay let's see if kig breaks
camp he's been known to do his own thing
okay
no ballerina
oh you're doing the popular change all
right so it's unanimous all of us
valerie you can just move on he's going
if i lose this yeah everyone's trying to
get everybody trying to get these
guaranteed wins these w's let's go
hold up uh which one did we do
anticipated it's next i just vote myself
you're ridiculous all right so just yeah
just go to that you don't you don't have
to exit you don't have to exit just hit
the up e where it says previous to the
next category at the top okay so we'll
go to the next one all right so
and just the most anticipated game yeah
or miss anticipated games
god of war ragnarok horizon forbidden
west and i love this next name the
sequel
let's go
star phil let's go what we doing mike
what are we doing oh man what are we
doing now i believe this is the fan
voted on one i could be wrong but i
think this is the heavily fan voted on
one way in here it's sponsored by prime
gig
remember it's recognizing an announced
game that has demonstratedly illustrated
potential to push the gaming medium
forward um well you know here's the deal
you know i host an xbox podcast and i
usually bleed a lot of green and
starfield i'm very excited about i am a
huge soulsborne fan so i love the idea
of elden ring but i do not
go against the power of those three
games in the middle so this is going to
be a tough one
each one is going to have a lot of love
right nintendo showing zelda breath of
the wild people go wild for horizon
forbidden west i know a lot of people
can't wait to battle those robot
dinosaurs being included but i'm gonna
go with god of war ragnarok i think what
they did with 2018 or 2016 whatever year
that was was really something special
and people are excited to go back so got
a war for me okay okay stop voting at it
live what is this
voting live do that on your own sir
unfold it man do it hold your own time
get off my back
first time get off my back you
this is a really hard one because i want
to say star filled
but i feel like
i got to go with the legend of zelda
sequel like i don't know why like to me
i feel like
i feel like they about to lose ratchet
and clay for game of the year so they go
give them something else man but but
part of me is like this elden ring was
hitting good so like but i don't know
that that
that legend of zelda brand is so strong
it's probably going to right hook
everyone yeah i'm going to catch the
vote because it grays out everything
else so people can see it right thank
you so much okay i'll vote after you yes
please all right luisa for your votes
oh man recognizing an announced game
that his
potential isn't to push the medium
forward next year
starfield i think people are worried
that it's just it's more elder scrolls
and fallout
okay okay breath of the wild doesn't
feel like it's even coming out next year
and i don't feel like the thing is after
seeing ragnarok i think
it just it looks great but it's more god
more same okay i see what you guys are
going which leaves two honestly bro what
you do this recent reaction did you do
it
elden ring
wait you're going against you going
against alloy song yo
the the recent the recent reaction to
elden ring and that little whatever
whatever test they had whatever people
went crazy
and elden ring
i have people going crazy that i've seen
that aren't souls players because this
seems to be the most accessible souls
game what that means i don't know but it
just feels like don't buy it the most
it's the most imminent game right
because it's one in february or whatever
uh i'm gonna go elder ring okay all
right all right king i'm curious this is
a tough one cake would you ain't nothing
tough about this god of war oh
you know what it is it gets the dust off
the playstations so
you said the most anticipated game
they are dying for a win they have been
[ __ ] so many l's right now oh my god
these xbox dudes is running all over the
place they're not voting for elder ring
because elder ring is on both platforms
we ain't voting for that they don't care
about nintendo let that 480p game do
what it's gonna do and you know horizon
horizon is the the step kid though is
the skeptic kid that's going to hold him
down to the real main event
you know what it is it's like chicken
mcnuggets
can hold you down but it's not a burger
so and they used to eating burgers so
and it's not gonna be starfield so if
this is friend voted
no
you got god
god oh god news is thirsty oh god oh oh
god of his god who alright no doubt love
to be this is tough this is tough man um
if i got to do process of elimination
out of every one of these that could be
legit
i got star fills my heart and i hate to
say this too
but it's like you know they started we
don't know what it is yet
so it's the unknown so i can't go there
just yet and then to saul's point
it may be in that vein of the of the
elder scrolls kind of space so i don't
know how that's gonna hit yet um
i'm gonna switch gang all day but i
don't know if that even comes right i
don't know if you're if breath comes
you're right man it's it's nice so now
it leads me down to the final three
and horizon look crazy like horizon
really looked good
surprisingly i'm gonna put it over
god of war be only because i felt god of
war felt a little insane
which so for me my choice comes down the
horizon forbidden west in el nino even
though i know the power of god a while i
know i'm wild i know the power
i'm going with some i'm going with
eldering from everything it says the
most anticipated yeah i think it is
because with jeff kegley jumped on stage
and he was so hyped to make that
announcement and like people been dying
for that game an open world souls and
i'm not even souls like that i'm going
held and ranked man i'm going to hit it
go for it god bless all right
next one next one next one
we don't otherwise
yeah previous yeah mm-hmm
so
debut indeed we got the artful escape
the forgotten city king of bridges
spirits sable and valhalla let's get it
mike
play the art full escape everyone it's a
great time a lot of fun times
play forgotten city awesome murder
mystery with time loops you'll enjoy
canaan bridge of spirits is beautiful
it's fun i have not played stable but i
do remember a time in our world where
velheim took over the entire planet for
a short period of time and it is tough
to go against that so i am gonna go
with velheim but a little bit me says
maybe cana bridges spirits but i'm gonna
go with velheim i'm gonna be different
okay okay i feel that attic
i ain't going second every time someone
else all right so all right um
i got king i know what i'm voting okay
okay so awful escape love it um
forgotten city very nice very beautiful
that's cool sable played it it's uh um
they have to fix that frame rate
they have to fix the frame rate on that
because i really wanted to get into that
game falheim like you said mike i'm not
gonna lie it was a it was a period of
time where that definitely was this
thing but kenneth i'm going with kenneth
bridges
the reason why is because they were so
thirsty in september and he got a big
block you're the best you're the best it
always got to be a subtle shot it always
got up
that that was it for them that was it
that was their christmas encouragement
i love him i love him he's always got a
thumbs up
you know i think i know what i'm doing
but you know what you're doing so yeah
yeah i mean it's cana it's canaan i
haven't played artful escape forgotten
city or sable
um i tried valheim and yes like this
year january february kind of belonged
to belheim like you listen up you listen
to podcasts in january february it was
valheim okay um but because of how
when you i think a lot of console gamers
aren't playing on pc they're not seeing
what valheim is yeah yep yeah
i'm going to cana okay
it's the one that looks like a cartoon
it just feels like the one that most
people would vote for i'm gonna go
against the grain i'm gonna lose this
but i'm going with my heart
but i don't care nobody say that
forgotten city is fire that forgotten
city is amazing like people that
actually played it the story that's how
you do a time loop game i'm running with
forgotten city no question that's my
joint right there so i'm rocking out
write it down continue
i'm gonna go i see since cog
see this is about politics since cog
went with
with the forgotten city i'm gonna go
with the other lords that way at least
if i lose three other people lose no
doubt i'm going to shoot myself
part of me wants to go with snow bike
but
like i do agree with saul that like when
it comes to like pc and console i think
it's going to be like a little bit hard
to resonate with that with certain of
the people voting so i'm gonna go with
cana because
it's all paulie i didn't even play it
but i know that if i get it wrong three
other lords down
playing the game play it again play the
game
knock out city it takes two
monster hunter rise new world and van
halen
you got some really great games on the
list uh shout out to monster hunt to
rise which was really really fun it
takes two is awesome and joseph ferris
and that team has banged on another one
again and i got to give him love big
shout out to velen studios who created
knockout city that was a very well done
game i knew it didn't have the biggest
legs but i really enjoyed that but i'm
going to go with new worlds this game
for the past couple of months and i
think when you look at this list new
world is going to skyrocket to the tippy
top here no doubt anybody want to jump
but who confident neighbor i'll go i'll
go i got to say new world okay i'm going
to give it to new world too
damn new world yeah you just dig through
your office i know you're oh my god
you know deep down inside you know deep
down inside you want to pick back for
blood you know deep down inside that you
feel like that's good
no i listen
it's not going to be definitely i
wouldn't blame you if you went with that
that vibe's off
nah nah i'm good
[Laughter]
um but you're going i'm giving it takes
two
[Applause]
that's a good one you know why
because it's because
it is the most unique it enforces it's
first of all you watch it
right
i saw you guys playing i saw you guys
playing
and it has some of the most unique
mechanics and scenarios for multiplayer
gamepl
where you going
okay so um valheim beautiful game
nice multiplayer um
monster hunter rise yeah are we sleeping
are we sleeping y'all no one's
saying that
it's it was cool capcom did they thing
um
knockout city
uh i picked it up
it it had potential yeah but it never
truly excelled in the spaces that i
needed it to yeah
um
it takes two
out of all the games here
it's essential to play multiplayer yes
like it's essential like you know um and
the mechanics behind it is incredible
my my heart goes to back for blood
but um wow it didn't do
what left for dead did okay and i don't
know why i feel that i can't put my
finger on point i think because it's its
formula has been done before and i think
left 4 dead was just so
like unique back in the day yeah yeah
but it's something it's something it
should have hit harder didn't it i feel
like and i don't understand why it's not
so what we're doing
but i'm gonna go with new world
uh because
i had a friend on my friend's list and
i'm playing uh destiny he said let me
tell you something you're not gonna see
me again for the next six months yes and
i said what are you talking about he
said new world is coming out tomorrow
and uh i'll take i'll see you in six
months
and i haven't seen him
it's really good this team has done a
really good job with the mmo formula
it's not far off the beaten path but
adding the active combat like they did
it really is engaging and fun this team
did a great job with like nobody goes up
against the king which is wow right very
few can do it like final fantasy has and
very little have survived right but like
this game has come out very strong so i
got to give them some credit for
creating something in a space where not
many people live anymore yeah no this is
a tough one i agree um
back for blade i agree with king back
for blood didn't hit like i thought
knockout city was okay
monsanto rise i really can't come
because i didn't play it but i didn't i
didn't feel like i heard the buzz from
that valham i did you know um
it comes down to it takes two versus new
world for me um
to the letter of the law it takes two
should win it does say co-op but i think
it takes two is gonna take some other
awards i'm gonna roll with mike i'm
going with new world
like king said i have destiny content
creators and players who stop destiny
for that game so i know what's going on
so that that's what i'm going with that
good out we can push it forward look i i
do want to point out that mike can't go
first every time because some of you
going with him okay so that's true all
right
all right so we'll switch up the order
i'll reverse it keegan start the next
one what do you think like mike has some
inside yeah because he thinks
that's what it is that's what it is i
know it's mike sydney you feel i feel
like it's influencing okay
like some of you don't know what these
games are like i'm going with mike
we got a lead on that dolly we got the
best sports slash racing game come on
2021 fifa 2020 baby horzo horizon 5 hot
wheels unleashed in writer's republic
listen man
y'all know what this is can we all just
say forza movie know what this is you
know what everyone says playgrounds town
this is the consolation award i don't
know let's
and i'm good i'm good thank you yeah
really really huge out there in europe
and we know
it's definitely the goat when it comes
to football so yours is fifa people okay
yeah yeah yeah
you got hot wheels on the leash and i
thought that
[Music]
came and did something completely
different in the space yeah and anytime
i can go from a bike to
a i like you in that space it really did
something different and i'm and i'm i'm
gonna have to say forza horizon 5
better jump
put it this way has anyone here not
voting for horizon fight that's the
question i'm not i'm not oh okay i know
i'm voting i'm voting for okay who's not
so good mike
no i'm on board with ford's horizon five
i mean king did say something well with
writers to public hot wheels was fun
fifa is the goats f1 is huge right now
they're really having a great time with
f1 2020 into 2021 but it's forza's year
it is sad like you said this is the
consolation award and that hurts
age of empires 4
evil genius 2 world domination
humankind
inscription uh i don't know
you got it you got it
and microsoft flight simulator i'm
jumping out the window micro uh flight
similar all day
taking off with the airlines let's go
buckle up i'm gonna say i'm gonna set
agent van parker
are you sure on the technicality of it
on the technical is not with that
no so i feel like you and carl can have
a winner here you just go with it go
with the flow man go with that what you
doing i'm going to keep it real
there's been a lot of talks crazy age of
empires oh that's fine no no no age of
age of empires but again it's still sort
of limited to
pc players
i'm going with inscription oh
what we don't know about well did that
work for solve last time with haiti no
but that yeah i think that haiti
i mean you you played inscription i
don't i know i will say last year saw a
pc game won this mike what we doing
i i love age of empires four and i'm
very close with that over there i think
what relic did
really i mean brought some life back
into that franchise that everybody knows
and loves from way back in the day and
if you haven't the hands-on history like
oh yeah the fun history channel things
that they did down to the channel
i only played that game just to watch
tribute shades and learn about
falconeering and stuff it was awesome
shout out to the mountain from game of
thrones
oh my god shout out to him i'm going to
give it to uh microsoft flights
what that team has done is truly
incredible i love it
let's go
oh
i'm so low in this yeah what you doing
yeah what y'all doing okay so um
king we are the winners well microsoft
yeah this is true microsoft flights in
them though anytime i can fly over
melrose project and see my house
yes that kind of takes me back i went
past yankee steve all that stuff it was
kind of crazy and it made me feel away
but i'm going to tell you something i've
never seen a crowd go crazy in the pc
crowd when asian empire stood up okay
and it was being announced in the
weighted are you sure you want to vote
that let her i'm gonna go with age of
empires because i'm gonna tell you right
now
i'm one of those little dudes i like to
to micromanage people and make them do
things so
that right yeah that's my little that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that's my
little girl that's my little pleasure
having these new dudes go to war and i'm
sitting there playing god i love that
love that addict oh agent five yeah i've
already voted let's go
oh all right so the best family game for
the best appropriate for family play
inspector and genre of platform or
everything nintendo
number one it takes two
mario party superstars new pokemon snap
mario
uh super mario 3d plus bowser fury and
warrior where get it together
oh what are we doing mike this is hard
i'll take the lead on this one so
we talk about joseph ferris and the team
and we really love your takes too i
don't know if it fits in the best family
for me on this one yeah
it is interesting that a a game about
two adults about to become divorced and
leave a fan leave a daughter by herself
it's like hey look at that family game i
get the game play but the story
definitely doesn't fit for me
but uh i'm gonna jump on actually uh
mario 3d world and bounces fury was a
ton of fun a really great time i think
mario superstars that mario party really
did a great job with online play on like
the last mario party they did so i'll
give it to that pokemon snap that was a
flash in the pan that they tried to
recreate from the 90s that just did not
kick off like i think they wanted it to
uh that was like a week long so i'm
gonna go with uh mario 3d world here
okay anybody else wants to put the fish
okay
yeah i'll take it okay go ahead i no no
you can go first okay
i'm going to take um i mean it takes it
was beautiful like mike said
you want that new pokemon snap that's
what yours is right well i think the
problem with the pokemon snap was the
fact that they didn't have the 3d
printer to go with it
you know that little printed thing that
we had that was on the back of the thing
that we printed out that really worked
back then for me um
[Music]
warioware
get it together
that looks so family for orientated king
it's not even close but the the super
mario 3d world it was just an extension
like a little dlc
um a game that came out already i gotta
go at mario party cause there's nothing
like a mario party soft
i'm going with 3d world balls this year
because it takes two again yeah i agree
i don't know
game about divorce i don't know
bring the family together yeah
mario party superstars sort of came and
went there wasn't a lot of people said
it was better than the last one and
obviously the last one had just gotten
online play which it didn't have for the
whole first year or whatever and change
that it was out
um so i just didn't hear a lot of people
talk about like yeah this is it
um there was more further around 3d
world because 3d will remember and then
you can play that four players uh and
that
yeah it's 3d world warrior no way
pokemon snap no yeah
i'm the same as yusof i'm i'm exact same
thing again i'm going with the
mario's world
where you get the vote no doubt hey you
shot your shot everybody voted we good
no no i i i haven't bothered i'm going
with mario party superstar
no this is where me and king are in the
winning circle you guys are saying how
did this happen again this is it
previously they went one year fighting
game yeah
demon slayer
virtual fighters 5 ultimate showdown
mike what are we doing
this is so much fun to see the fgc
community come out right there's so much
love and excitement around fighting
games and it's been really cool you know
when we talked about me and growing up
like fighting games has always been at
the forefront and there's kids that you
know that love it
cog you told some great stories when you
first came on about the neighborhood and
fighting games and what that was like
right
and so for me when i look at this
there's a couple of standouts but i am
gonna go with guilty gear i love the
artwork of guilty gear i love the
gameplay i'm going to go with guilty
gear no doubt i'm jumping right behind
you um
yeah guilty gear i want to shout out my
boy um lord ty from bloodthegaming.net
i've learned so much about this game
through him for his amazing articles and
i would be remiss i was like man i
didn't know it was popping like that so
yeah that that that's why when my heart
wanted to save virtue fighters but
i i got i gotta i gotta i gotta give
guilty kids dude but which i got
yeah it's guilty gear um
i think this is i think we all could
yeah yeah demon demon slayer is one of
those that on on popular attic fraud and
listening by the way and taking notes
continue i just want to let you know i
just want to make sure he does not play
oh guys
definitely
they think he's slick he think he's like
i know what he's doing
hands down if you think about the best
fighting game here it's guilty gear 100
i mean virtual fighter 5 is amazing but
it's old so you know
the thing about it is the popularity of
demon slayers with worries yeah
you're right about that you're right
about it but i'm i'm going to have faith
in the fgc
and i'm going to go with guilty gear no
doubt is it unanimous addict
yeah i'ma go with you
i don't even know what's going on you
fraud
what is that
playing the game
for the best game design
with rich player customization and
progression including massive
multiplayer experiences
we got cd projekt red cyberpunk 2077
monster hunter rise scarlet nexus
whatever that is
i'm going with monster hunter rice
wow okay
okay okay no i'm switching i'm not a
liquid
anyone else wants to put their chest on
the line yeah i i'm up i'll take it
let's go um okay so if that patch ever
did came out for cyberpunk i would have
voted there but uh it didn't as far as
that game didn't come out yet yeah yeah
rise um
a whole different world got a chance to
uh shout out to game pass for uh the
scarlet nexus and dudes was bigging up
it it's it's it's a very good game
when you need the time to sit down and
play tales of rise arise oh man i love
the tails franchise uh i think they do
great rpgs
but shimla got me uh tencent five
that's the wave okay okay fair enough
fair enough mike and solve
this is this is king attic on the
winning circle energy right now
mike mike you want to be there with this
man
go ahead mike
you know it's it's fun because i i'm
good i want to be king right now and
vote with my heart and say scarlet nexus
because i had a blast with that right
and i just know that's not gonna be the
one right sometimes you stand by the the
people that took you to the dance you
know so i'm gonna go with scarlet nexus
even though in the background
i know
that the other three besides cyberpunk
are probably the front runners that you
should be looking at besides this one
okay
it's off
it's tough
let's get it so yes you want to go with
that cyberpunk that's what you want
i'm surprised you guys are going to
megami tensei that that is a super
hardcore rpg
addict picked that yeah i don't know
and king and that's
that's super hardcore i think it's
between that and tails of her eyes
but i'm going with my heart
monster hunters people monster hunters
so damn near eight million cop yeah
people sleeping i don't but the thing is
i for some reason i don't think they're
going to give it to this category
it's weird it just feels like
yeah prove me wrong soft pick it prove
me wrong
tails feels like a safer bet for
whatever reason
about pics
i'm going with tails
i'm going with t i got a shout out mr
maddie please you probably shout to show
a capria here too in the chat
xbox kid i see the xbox drive in there
salute to you yeah man everybody been
hit me up with 10 don't get me wrong
shimagami could win this
shimagami can win this i feel mike's
pick nexus is a heart pick great game
kind of did astro train better but yeah
once if he wins that if
it comes down to mike wins this whole
thing because of this scarlet this is
this is going to be a critical yeah
turning point with this award so let's
let's move over that's i got my tails
i'll go over the tails
so we got best action adventure game
marvel guardians of galaxy metro dread
psychonauts 2 ratchet and clank rift
apart and resident evil village this is
hard
wow
i'm like yo
i ain't jumping out the window [ __ ] i
need to listen
you gotta go first get that kick this is
all
all right so ratchet and clank um that's
not gonna win because then one game with
a year they already said it yeah
so you know the html yeah he's gonna
file
no you know that that that that could be
it was just like it no it was the
it happened with multiple games
that game would be anything like happy
with multiple goals
psychonauts to
metroid bushes um
jesus
guardians of the galaxy versus resident
evil
tough
i think the goat is here i think
resident evil is the goat i i listen i
love how that big vampire looks oh i i
know lady dammit
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
oh man this
out the is
who's going to jump right in order for
the fire king went first i'll jump in
and defy king king i really love that
pick and i had a great time with village
i did think it kind of slowed down and
hit a lull after the dollhouse which i
truly believe is one of the best
resident evil sequences ever that had me
on the edge of my seat screaming and
crying which was a ton of fun but i
think the back half really slowed down
for me uh of course king i told you i've
never played a nintendo really first
party game so metroid dread in the
bushes is right
[Applause]
i love psychonauts too and marvel's
guardians of the galaxy truly wowed me i
give them a lot of credits but i believe
you know king this is the snowball
effect this is when the snowball starts
to be pushed down the hill let's go
we're gonna see a lot of rewards so
ratchet and clank will win this and uh
maybe my game of the year might be
similar but i think this is the snowball
that starts to go down the hill right
now okay yeah this is tough i jump in
all right and this is where mike
looked over at me and said bye
[Music]
i feel whoever wins these type of wars
is gonna win it
because this is the top man i'm just
playing marvel it's amazing all right
okay oh you're going jumping at it you
could jump in
i'm i'm between
metro dread and marvel guardians of the
galaxy
i don't
ratchet and clank was average as hell i
don't think that's good um
psychonauts 2
i wouldn't consider that like an action
adventure game like i know technically
it is but i wouldn't consider it more
action platformer yeah yeah like
like resident evil village is definitely
a possibility
obama had to put my foot in the ground
and i know what you do i'm not i'm about
to hurt myself what you doing i'ma have
to say
guardians of the
couch i i feel like there's not a lot
i feel like this game was good and
they're gonna want to give it something
yeah and i don't think there's a lot of
room to give it anything but this i
think you wanted something addictive god
yes i mean let me let me
yeah i'm gonna stick with guardians yeah
i think you want something
it's tough i will say
i don't if guardian's gonna win this is
probably the only category i think it
got a shot at
dread is i think we sleeping on trad
though well see i tried was the one i
wanted to pick but i feel like
because it is a game of the year
contender
even if it doesn't win an award i think
in their eyes at this because i do think
a lot of this has to do with politics
and i think their visions will be like
dread got nominated for game of the year
like this is pretty much one of the only
rewards that i think they can give
guards at the galaxy right that's the
only one they got to do is i don't think
i mean i'll be surprised if it went the
other way i'm surprised no one's going
with psychonauts this is interesting
um man this is tough i'm not gonna go
with ratchet clank not for the reason
y'all give i think i have my eye on it
for another specific award i think it's
you're going to win so i'm not going to
vote for it here
um resident i'm with you attic it should
win but at the platforming aspects and
stuff we were talking about
so it comes down to dread and guardian
god man guardians are so good and it
could win this
oh this is tough are we gonna go
i'm gonna go with dread
i'm gonna go with dread on this one i'm
gonna go safe i'm gonna say this is
gonna win this thing i think that's a
solid pick because
if it doesn't win game of the year yeah
it could be i don't think
yeah i i think game of the year is just
too too tough
and if dread's gonna just kick laughing
we'll see this this is where we split
everyone's gonna split here i love when
addict be like making you feel good
about your pixie dust he's the best yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
first psychology i know what he hears
right yeah
continue continue all right no there's
no i haven't gone yet yes no i mean
that's what i'm saying
oh
uh
res evil i haven't finished yet so no i
can't talk on that ratchet and clank
thought about what you played it's about
what you're thinking about
ratchet and clank yeah stand on that
metroid square that's what you gotta do
you gotta
anyway
this is the one this is the kick it'll
be a great
ratchet and clank i kind of i kind of
agree with attic like it's it's a
beautiful ps2 game uh in a lot of ways
like see this this is what's getting me
right the description of best action
adventure for best action adventure
combining combat with traversal and
puzzle solving yeah like if you
that's
that's measured
i read that description
damn it i've heard people saying that
the combat in marvel's gardens the
galaxy is just it's fine
i'm going with dread i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna
all right so the next one is
best action game oh
back for blood chivalry two
death loot far cry 6 and return boom
i'll jump i don't know can i go first
okay
okay so so so um back for blood again
it's something wrong
and and i'm going to give it a proper
review and go over and i'm going to
probably send an email to the devs to
fix that for me turtle rock please i
need y'all back
um chivalry too we had so much so much
fun i'm so glad it got nominated so glad
you later yeah please go up on the site
and just check out that stream
yeah
shout out to microsoft and def loop oh
man
act like it don't even exist on
playstation you digless
gave them something to eat and that was
great you gave them something to eat boy
i'm so happy that they like the meal
that we gonna get for free
messy um
far cry 6.
i am not gonna lie to performances in in
that game
he he's he's come a long way from do the
right thing
oh facts
that's a good call that's a good yeah
yeah this this broken
game
uh-oh he keeps rearing its ugly little
head are you okay and these dudes keep
trying to act like this game got
something
going for it and
they and this is the one that was
bricking consoles that forced the
company to get by the developer to shut
them up and i gotta go with the one that
forces a purchase which one like if they
said it's not our game it's the consoles
and they got purchased the following
week returns shut them up because your
wife can't testify against you so i'm
going with return on this one here okay
i see i see the bicep mike what are we
doing
yo shout out to silvery that's right
that was a fun time
i'm so happy to see it there yeah that
was a fun time back for blood just
something that's missing is right king
far cry i really enjoyed yara i think
that was a nice return to form after a
couple of
entries into that series where i was
like i don't want to play far cry
anymore i had a good time with you i
actually felt like that was the second
best far cry yeah it was very nice to
jump in and feel it again now it comes
down king you you nailed it on the head
here's two
it's death looper eternal in my mind
right we look at this and we look at
death loop or eternal and return
got a lot of buzz right a lot of buzz
over there but what arcane brought and
you know i'm gonna be king for a minute
gave to playstation for a little time
exclusive uh no i'm gonna go with i'm
gonna go with death loop here i think
death loop had a lot of energy a lot of
people talking but those two are the
games to watch here
so get out of here
i'm going with chivalry too wow oh yes
crazy
so he's in all right um
damn
mike said it beautifully oh
back for blood
no i'm with king it's just we're happy
it's there but there is some it's
untangible that just off that's not
getting that left for dead ends but what
happens is there's chivalry too that's
my heart
no old school cog would have did it at
it and did that
but i cannot go with my heart on this
one it comes down
far cry 6 as great as it is
a lot of people i just want to point out
that yes chivalry 2 wins oh this is your
greatest this year and i'm a fraud
because i would technically i should be
voting for children but i'm trying to
win this is crying your lord i'm trying
to win i've never been crowned i need to
win
[Laughter]
so i'm going to say like mike said it
comes down to me between death loop and
return
and i believe both are also in the game
of the year running
right so somebody
got to get a consolation prize fraternal
isn't game of the year someone gotta get
a consolation and i'm with my man king
david i think this is the shot
if fraternal's gonna win
this is the only shot because i i just
definitely
winning
listen def loop is that wave
yeah everyone loves death sorry maddie i
know you got your issues because you're
an arcane fanboy and you have your
issues but
listen
this is the only one shot i think return
on god i'm going to eternal i wouldn't
return what you got solved
small he got the dirty smile oh man it's
the same you know what it is
obviously back with blood chivalry too
you know no
no
no no
the eternal question
for me is just that there's a lot of
people that stand that game yes
yes and as see death loop is action but
you can play it stealthily yeah play it
differently fraternal is pure
pure action
it's pure action and when it works
it's
the action is kind of crazy
i think death is getting something else
i'm going to return let's get it moving
on everybody's going to hell we separate
we all separate for the pack yeah this
is where you put boots to the ground
let's go
all right so next one
do we have to do best videos yeah let me
do vr sir oh
yes yes yes yes i'll do it quick since i
know that yeah yeah okay yeah you do
yeah i'm going resident evil for all day
i'm going ready yep
the new vr adopter quest two is out
going with me see here's my mindset i'm
going whatever everyone else goes with
because it's a win or lose for me i
don't lose yes i feel that i win because
if you go if we all miss it
then i still win because no one got up
even though loan echo 2 is fire i have
to give a shout out to that but it's not
going to yeah i don't they messed it up
yeah because i mean low knuckle 1 was
crazy these are the guys that did um the
order 1886 yeah um
echo one was crazy
not for you and it be it ain't really if
y'all got a quest please play wrestling
before it is absolutely amazing mike you
was all resolute for two or what was
your fault i don't know what it is i
like resident evil 4 but you know what
i've been preaching hitman all year long
hitman 3 did not get any love and gave
him the air
this is it
one dude that's on the opposite side
i'll go with him man three for fun
that's like staying on your square mic
stand on your square i respect it
okay all right so we're ready we're
ready let's go
innovation accessibility
and it's got a sponsor too i know what
i've got innovation presented by chef
chevrolet
cool man
yeah do we i mean let's go with mike
first mike first
i'm curious i'm curious
honestly i don't know to be honest with
you that's all i want to hear this is
one for me i honestly don't know and i
don't have a clear favor because i
thought there was some other games that
pushed accessibility
a little bit more than these games in
front of me that i thought would have
been on this list
so one that really stuck out to me when
i spoke with
steve uh blind gamer steve and steven
spahn absolutely
you know what i mean i would i would
have to lean towards forts of five would
probably be my one when i look at this
list there was a couple others this year
that i thought would have been somewhere
here but i guess not so i'm going to go
with 45 for me i'm saying forza before
it's all day for me
yeah
the beautiful things i'm seeing online
with people with accessibility plans
best community supports
apex legends destiny 2 final fantasy
online fortnite and no man's sky
how can i go okay let's go first uh
you're trying to mess me up
all right i have not gone first one time
um
i can't pick that's dude this year i
love you destiny you know i do but your
community support this year with that
transmog and some other bungles
i love you though i love you um which
basically comes down
i'm gonna jump out the window y'all i'm
gonna do something crazy
i'm gonna do something crazy
i think we're sleeping on no man's sky
here man i think we're sleeping because
i think they keep iterating and they
keep fixing it bringing it like new
stuff every time i look and i know if i
don't i know apex i don't fortnight i
don't
but i'm going with the log shot go shout
out to show off murray in them dudes i'm
gonna shoot my shot in the corner
again that's why i lose i don't know
this one reeling himself all the way
through
yeah
can i go yes please
fortnight
oh you go for that solid w
there's nothing better you know there's
absolutely zero
nothing better as far as the key i would
have went with apex if fortnite wasn't
going last all right so i'm honestly got
to save fortnite because i mean final
fantasy yeah yeah okay whatever destiny
we already know your bungles or whatever
i know for a fact i don't play fortnite
but i can't deny exactly how that how
the community is that is ill and you see
right there you better get it together
what about you solve
ff14
yeah i gotta go with 14 too oh bye
i like i like apex i think respawn is
really well known with the community of
doing great stuff but yeah ff14 let's go
with that one boys
all right
cog already went so
next one it's it's brought to you by
verizon just want to put that
impact league of legends wild rift
marvel future revolution and pokemon
unite oh wow that's a hard one oh best
mobile oh boy
oh boy oh and this is it it's brought to
you by verizon
thank you very much
a big shout out to pokemon unite i'll
speak up on that one i did never played
on mobile but i just really love that
they brought some energy back into the
moba arena that has been dominated by
league and dota for so long and i really
think that that team created something
fun for beginners to veterans pokemon
united is an awesome game but i'm gonna
go with how i feel and that is gentian
impact okay and gentian impact is just a
juggernaut in this space so it's going
to be gentian for me i'm going against
it same
me too
anybody not going against
walker man i don't know why i gotta go
with them i'm probably gonna lose
she's really good yeah fantastic
the only reason i'm going with my heart
is because i think there's a good chance
genji doesn't win
fair enough let's go
best indy
12 minutes
death store
kina bridge of spirits and loop hero
loop here is actually a good game yeah
yeah people are sleeping on that it's
hard too it's hard too
i'm going with that store okay i'm going
with death star um
oh man
all of us speak all right jeff is this
everybody quiet um
to me it comes i love 12 minutes but i
can't i had some some a couple issues
that i couldn't get over but i loved it
i'm glad it's the description i wish i
played it because i'm going to have more
insight
so it comes down to how you pronounce it
this is the shot for canada to win
but death's doors i don't think they're
gonna let that stop yeah like that's the
door was a movie man it was good too
he tried to get me to jump out the
window listen
yeah damn though this is the oh i don't
know if cannon can't win anything else
if it don't win here
that's the thing so in my voting kenna
would not come away with anything if it
doesn't win here oh they already won
best whatchamacallit best debut indeed
we had yeah we did we have it for debut
i did i don't know
death star's got to get it that store
got it it did so much and then i played
playstation
yeah death store that store i'm gonna uh
for me addict you can put me down as
kana i'm gonna go on the opposite side
of you all to steal the points here i
really love acid nerve and death store
and i think they deserve some love there
but i mean you all talked about it on
best indie debut you all gave a lot of
love to
you know it's hard to go against it for
best indies so i'm going to go with that
one yep
best ongoing game
game jesus christ
oh okay okay
i i'm sorry
yeah you got to go first off thanks for
after this um
whoever i think it goes to devolver
either way um damn happy
we're really talking about inscription
and a lot of people just got death's
door now
oh yo you you alright you better
remember you got two platforms you got
two platforms that's just got it now
yeah yeah
yeah but all the people voting have been
having the game let's move on
listen this is song standing on the
screen with that description i love it
we got
best ongoing awarded to a game for
outstanding development and ongoing
content that evolves the players
experience over time solve you're going
next yes you're first
off that's ongoing
14.
okay okay
yes
final fantasy 14.
mike
really disappointed we don't see sea of
thieves on here afterwards
that was such a great game and brought a
lot of energy there so shout out to that
team very sad not to see them here yeah
you know what i play a lot of war zone
and i'm always impressed by war zone
king said it so well where else are you
going to get an ariana grande concert
inside of the video game but fortnite
like that stuff is truly incredible even
for people who are just casual fans of
video games the idea of being able to do
that in the game nobody does that when
you look at this right nobody does that
but final fantasy 14 has so much energy
behind it this year especially the new
dlc is coming out here very shortly like
the the hype around this game is
palpable so we're going to go with final
fantasy 14 yeah i think this is where i
course correct when i went against final
fantasy the last time and i'm jumping
back on a ship and quit
getting back in pocket with the final
fantasy this time as much as i think
fortnite against you do deserve all of
those always legends oh nice oh
yeah i feel like they're going to give
the other one final fantasy and
regardless because everyone's locked so
i can talk
regardless regardless of final fantasy
like it's been doing really good but
it's big big stuffs after
the the awards i think it meant it's
after yeah
yeah so i i
i don't think they're going to really
count that experience but apex has had a
lot of content this year and so is war
zone but i'm gonna go with apex because
i don't like warzone but shout out to
what mike said it says travis ucc of
thieves is not here seattle thieves is
supposed to be here for sure
continue that's another one that that
the millions love it yeah they they do
millions
oh games was it games for impact
yeah gains for impact for a
thought-provoking game with a pro-social
meaning or message
i don't know none of this i know but
we're going with it
before your eyes boyfriend dungeon
uh
chevrolet uh a colorful tale life is
strange true colors and no longer home
hey hey mike what's your what's your
vote
i'm actually i'm actually the wrong
person to ask because i've played none
of these but of course being around the
kind of funny crew we have a lot of
diverse voices and i will say if we ask
blessing janet greg and the team right
what the [ __ ] you're gonna beat the drum
for chicory and or life is strange so
those are the two games that i know my
team at kind of funny will definitely be
behind
so if i had to lean one of the other a
lot of word around chicory but i think
life of strange carries a lot of weight
with that franchise and what that
message has always been yeah and i'mma
go with life is strange too you're
ridiculous i was going off the joke
because i didn't play it but um yeah
i've heard tremendous things about life
of strange true colors so
very diverse game very inclusive and a
lot of a good message from what i
understand so yeah that's what i'm going
what you got king and solve
life is strange everybody says unanimous
all right let's do it
best performance this is going to be a
hard one okay can i go first yes yes
i love everybody here
i thought everybody did a fantastic job
in these spaces
[Music]
but
the one
actor that stands out to me is john
carlo esposito
[Music]
he is on such a tear
talk that talking he is absolutely
phenomenal
and and and you know me and addicts
talked about this on the attic show
addict said that he wasn't in a lot of
scenes but did he control the scenes
that he was in when he was in the scenes
and i have to say a resounding yes
so
i'm going with john carlos with esposito
because i know exactly where his genesis
was and to see exactly where his apex is
going
he's phenomenal and i think all his
other actors here
are just ascending where he's at a
primal alpha level anybody else want to
jump out the window know what they're
doing
uh i'm s oh you go
you're sure nobody i want to hear you oh
yeah
you should pass it out let it go because
you try to get the balls off i feel like
there's two death loops in here and part
of me feels like one of them's gonna win
this and yes like
i've it's but then like this is such a
hard
one because
the the chick from resident evil village
she was doing numbers at the beginning
of the year but like
i feel like what's the sad is i feel
like the far cry 6 i feel like that's
the last one that's gonna win it this
year like
uh the life is strange i didn't play
that but i you know that's the main
character so i'm assuming she did a
fantastic job there and like i i really
like julianna
and death loop but i like call this is
this is this is a horrible but i'm just
i'm i must say
this is going to the resident evil
village character because
i remember what like
all these did something but hers was a
movement
like
like sure it might have been for the
wrong reasons sometimes but
it was definitely a movement and a lot
of people really
she made memes like if if she didn't win
i think julianna might win because i
thought she did a fantastic job in death
loop and colt did too that's why i could
see any one of these winning like any
one of them but i'm gonna have to say
resident evil villain okay he's standing
there you're square he's still on the
screen
uh soft
i'm going with erica morgan alex jones
nice colors
i think giancarlo
hey giancarlo is obviously the like the
biggest name here but
uh he he
he gave a good performance right as your
typical villain but you know it is kind
of a very boring kind of a boilerplate
latino
villain
so nah
colt
i look at colt and i look at giuliana
juliana was much more interesting to me
colt felt like
that character could have been anybody
like it he's just i didn't like him
nearly as much as juliana juliana was so
good yeah and then lady demetris
demetrisco
when you look at the game you know she
was huge right everybody loved her but
when you look at the game she was had a
very small role in it ultimately
i think
yeah i think that alex chen if there's
any if people who are kind of they want
to put this game to the forefront
they're going to vote for erica moore
right and to give this game in its
message so i think it's her alex chen
um
this is hard uh yeah
i can see legit
cases for everyone on some level
i'm gonna go against death loop here
only because i feel the two may cancel
each other out
with with the voting
which then leaves it to lady
you know
ah this is tough action i heard a great
performance
i'm gonna go with king i'm going with
king i'm gonna go with jean carlo i
think that you know i listened to danny
shout out to daddy pena i was listening
to his interview
you know that's fine this is where the
winners and losers listen man
it wasn't a lot but he commanded every
seed he was in you know and i know
some don't like the tropes but uh i like
the truth
i mean
the thing about it is i'll be
disappointed if he wins but then you did
have mods did win two years ago
yeah that's good that's what i got
anybody didn't vote
i'm going with juliana
oh that's right i'm going with that one
she might win like everybody really
loved juliana yeah i think that's the
one to watch right here
best audio design
deathly forza horizon 5 ratchet clank
rift apart resident evil village
that's where we all lose we're going to
mess up here this is where we all mess
up somehow
man
i mean you like to lean towards four to
five because it sounds so good but i
don't think people want to reward just a
bunch of car sounds right and so that's
a big issue even though that team over
at playground really put a big effort in
elevating the audio in this one and you
can hear it you can feel it every time
you play right and so when i look around
i think of games that really impacted me
when i was listening and was turned off
all the lights and that's resident evil
village in return
i'm going to go with fraternal for me on
this one all right so let's let me talk
to the other lawyers briefly yes i
suggest the truce let's all pick one
yeah that's a good one you stay on your
square
you die where you stand
then how about we all pick cognitos
there
i'll go left
i'm with mike
i'm with mike
um
it isn't specifically
sound
but
you know all the videos that when that
game came out of the raindrops and
how it worked with the uh the dual dual
sense controller
um so that's part of the sound design
right how do you design it so that it
becomes like this encompassing sort of
experience
yeah return
i gotta go
i'm gonna do something stupid i think i
know what you're doing
and i'm gonna go with death luke oh
any particular reason just because we
doing something stupid that's what we're
doing
one i'm not going to get a ratchet and
clank
why why why i can't register
i'm just not and i i know all the best
audio design should go to forza
it should definitely go to forza because
to to get a lamborghini and um a ferrari
to sound completely different or a
lamborghini and a porsche to sound
completely different and bugatti to
sound different and to hear the breaks
and the squeals and little things like
that and going through puddles and muds
and stuff and i saw them when they were
uh
doing all that background stuff so
and then to have the the the music
that's inside the game that's part of
the audio uh design as well
so and and then the interaction with all
the characters talking to you and when
she can say my name david and you know
stuff like that so there's little stuff
that's that keys in there and i know
forza should win this but for some
bonkers reason
i think it's definite
okay okay who i'm giving
this to return
yeah um for return huh everybody pretty
much unanimous eternal that's what
that's what it is not me i have a king
except the king oh cognito
no no i didn't i didn't have to do that
i did that
um i'm with king though i don't think
force is going to win this one
i don't think i i as much as
people think so i don't think this is
the one for the win
i said i can't surprise me i thought he
was going to do something else he threw
me off
i think it's deflue
we have gone pretty much has anyone give
ratchet anything yet
i have
game of the year
can we
you eloquently brought those points up
yeah i'm about to die together i'm gonna
have to die together on this one because
i
i can't i what is i what i thought king
was gonna do resident evil it's it's
it is the most unique application of
sound design right think about think
about uh
uh hellblade when it came out right the
voices
exactly i don't know
yeah
send me your ears
let's go
moving on all right so
the next one is
best score and music it's kind of the
same but
i got this i think i got another one
with this yeah go just so i mean
best scoring music i got to go with the
artful escape oh it's
let me tell you something there's
nothing more exhilarating when you're
jamming going down the hill and you keep
it going and the world is lighting up
and you're hitting those jumps and you
could do this this could be the one
best score out of all those and i have
not played def loop or or
and i know
guardians of the galaxy should have
something in there but near replicant no
def loop don't think so because i didn't
hear any music when i was watching
people play the game and cyberpunk
definitely
i know i love that
but
at the same time
the artful escape
is all about music um
okay i'm i'm rolling i'm not just gonna
bs i'm gonna roll with you um for that
similar reason and then
i my heart wants to say guardians as the
80s baby that it'd be rocking in there
like it is like you i was smiling from
any air with african gay cable
but
it's not really original music it's
really like they took a soundtrack from
the joints oh think about it okay never
mind no don't think about that's not
what i need to think about because yeah
you do have the license on the tracks
right yeah about the score though the
score think about the original music
that's in the ada this is a static music
inclusive for score original song a
licensed soundtrack so they're basically
they're basically saying that counts
because basically y'all say yeah covered
both obviously the the license stuff is
what we remember right like the movies
whatever the case may be yeah but the
actual score score is fire
it's five oh my god it's fire wells this
is it yeah gang sausage my vote
go go get it go get it that's not
terrible
no i would have gave it off for escape
but under these rules it's allowing that
oh yeah yeah i believe if i look to him
it's gonna be if i lose the office
i'm going i'm going against the gray
i'll go i'm going to say near replicant
wow crazy
i feel like as far as like original
content and original composing
music
it does have a lot of really good stuff
in it
and i think this is the only award i've
seen this year
again i'm so tired i'll go back and
so
while he decides i
i'm doing i'm doing guardians um you are
full escape i would have agreed with you
king the thing is the artful escape
i feel like it should have been in sound
design because a lot of like the the
actual gameplay and platforming is
associated with the music in a way
that's super interesting and i don't
understand why they didn't put in sound
design instead of this
it might be right there too you might be
right i'm going i'm going guardian
everyone chose i'm going to go with
guardians i i will give artful escape
and king a big shout out i've never been
so into folk music in my life before
like
as this is like a new genre to me
listening to that i was like man like i
could just sit here and relax and hang
out but man yeah guardians has a killer
score awesome licensed music they have
their whole own star-lord band going on
with the music
there's a lot going on there so yeah you
got to give it to marvel gardens this
next one's crazy man this one is crazy
hard best art direction the artful
escape definitely early keno bridges
spirits
psychonauts 2
and ratchet and clank rectap go ahead
king go ahead king take it away uh
psychonauts too
tim schaefer i salute you sir okay what
about you uh snow bike mike what's your
where's guardians of the galaxy
first off really quick where's guardians
of the galaxy have you ever looked at a
character animation with that facial
tech and said oh my gosh like this team
did that there's been few and far
between games have really captured that
moment so good for them a little sad to
not see him here but i'm with king
psychonauts 2 what an art direction that
was that was far out fun took you on
different worlds shout out to
psychonauts 2. oh
um i'm going last i'm going oh yeah
all right
so you up for that i
see my
psychonauts 2 makes a whole lot of sense
my only thinking is like if you play
psychonauts 1 it's more of that like
they've done they've done it before
right let's do it don't do it so
don't do it don't do what i think you're
going to do because i think i'm doing
that what you doing
don't do it and then ratchet the same
thing like i said ratchet is a gorgeous
ps2 game it's what it is
um
damn but that camera is beautiful
let's get it
jesus i'm gonna say my vocals somebody
rigging my belt um i'm going with uh
ratchet and clank i think they the
graphical fidelity is just too much this
is the one i think they win this but i
get my belt right back
i'm gonna go with
i'm gonna go with psychonauts it's it's
just it is
that whole sort of
my thing is that they did it before man
you know what i mean like this isn't new
but it is the first time that this many
people have had the chance to experience
it so thank you for joining me i i'm
going to say the art will escape
i don't know
yes
yes
yeah what a ride what a ride
oh that was just my old pretty stuff oh
okay at the same time
just printed cartridges from amazon
salute to them
xbox so we
i'll go first since i chose the gold yes
please not last time best narrative for
outstanding storytelling and narrative
development in a game
ah this look i'm gonna say life is
strange
wow okay that's all they do
yeah
i feel like that's a good way that's a
good horse to ride
mike
uh you know it's tough i take a look at
this and i kind of ex-nave the easy
stories right of death loop we're moving
on guardians of the galaxy it's just a
superhero movie right with some touching
moments it takes two we talked about it
right we talked about two people
falling apart and drifting away from
each other and having to come together
and there was some fun storytelling
elements to that there was some four fun
ways where he tied gameplay into
storytelling and really made you keep
going on that but psychonauts too tim
schaefer and that team really connected
mental health and a lot of these you
know hurdles and obstacles again into a
fun and awesome way that kind of
sometimes just makes you think and take
a deep breath and go wow like i can't
believe they're addressing this issue
and the way they are is very interesting
and insightful so i will go with
psychonauts too on this one mike stole
all my points um literally that's what
that's how i like locked it down
look it takes two can deserve it but i
feel it's gonna win a lot of the
cooperative
stuff and you know unique stuff def loop
got a shot i mean it definitely does
you know life restraint i think is a
lock for the games with change kind of
stuff
right and i'm not saying that the
narrative is not good
but
if psychonauts is going to win something
this is the category for me to win i i
just think and it's tough because
marvel's is fire but i think like man
second has got to take something
and i think this this is it it's gonna
it's down at the loop and not it's crazy
how close it's very all of this this is
probably the most competitive category
ever
i suggest i'm going psychonauts too yeah
i suggest whenever you get time snowbite
like go back and watch our other crowd
the lords like it's so one way but this
year it's so like nice like in the
middle
all right
you tend to okay best game direction
whoever goes last has to go first the
next time yes best game direction
jesus jesus
i kind of think
i wanted for outstanding creative vision
and innovation in game direction and
design
um
can we all just like look i know i've
been like [ __ ] on ratchet like what
this year sunday yeah
uh why is this here in this
category like dude never mind go go solo
oh can i go yeah go ahead go ahead
please
i'll take uh it takes two
i'll take it takes two for one please
thank you
all right
oh man mike what you doing
i will go first on the next one to make
it more fun for the iron lord podcast
listeners out there so i'll go first on
the next one so i was going to go last
uh this one is a very interesting one to
me when i break it down and i go through
all of the different ones i think of
stuff like that i love king with the it
takes too i love what joseph ferriss and
that team does and i know i sound like a
broken record because that game deserves
a lot of love and it's a lot of fun
returnal and what they did with that
kind of um
metroidvania like just constantly die
repeat rinse and wash their hands and
try again was very interesting and very
different on the main stage right is
what a lot of people saw that as arcane
continues to make games all about player
choice where you can do whatever you
want and you make it the way you want
and i mean it's a huge island where you
have to kill all these people at a
certain way however you wanted to go
it's tough i would love to lean into it
takes two but i think this is where
death loop takes it so i'm gonna go with
best game direction death loop
mike stole my exact points again like
literally that's how i nailed that
knocking down
again that game
every scenario is bespoke and unique
because the gameplay
it's necessary for the play this
this one's a classic addict's war let's
get it i'm saying return oh
okay okay because i feel like
some of these has done well
but it's not new i feel like fraternal
isn't new
but it's
newer like i feel like death loop
sure
that is like that that's like kind of
like a groundhog day like i don't think
that's that concept's really new it
takes two i would say because of a ways
out they just took that concept and they
made it better
and they brought in on it psychonauts 2
is all is really good but you know
we do have examples of platforms right
that's right doesn't deserve to be in
here
it's so disrespectful i feel like
fraternal the reason i feel like it's
fraternal is because it is the first
game that i feel like roguelike is being
tried in the triple a model yeah i think
that it is going to get it
yeah look all legit points i'm gonna i'm
gonna roll with def loop i think that
p a lot of people just are not
seeing the arcane
formula as much and this is their first
arcane game and to them that's
revolution no disrespect for it takes
two
i just think it'll win other things than
this i think definitely just going away
with this
and here it is game
number two is it takes two
number three is metroid dread number
four is psychonauts two
number five is blank and number six is
resident evil villain he's gonna blink
stuff
he's ratchety clank lift the parts
i'm gonna go first so we can have some
fun with the uh the lords of the realm
here but uh there are some snubs we will
not get into that
recipe shout out recipe shout out to
forza horizon 5. yeah
uh
what would it be for the game of the
year because it's about your game at the
end the games that you truly enjoy and
you love so always remember that when
you listen to this podcast
celebrate the game so you love share the
games you love let those developers know
that they did a great job when you look
at this list it's a heavy lineup we had
a really solid year right as we're in
the middle of a pandemic we've got to
play some great games and we've all
smiled and had some fun
it takes two i love you but you're out
metroid dread you're out psychonauts too
i i love you dearly but you're out
resident evil unfortunately you're out
and
sony and playstation always have some
big heavy hands
before you pick this is worth two points
okay we're two so this is my this is my
big moment because that's it you know
i'm gonna be going with blank at number
five i will go with rats click like rats
and clay came out hot in the summer it
really pushed the next gen tech that we
all wanted to see we all wanted to love
with the quick loading times and the
alternate worlds that it could go in and
out of the animation is beautiful the
voice acting was very very well done i
mean this is a great game and it is my
game of the year out of these five maybe
not my personal game of the year but my
game of the year out of these i should
say six my bad yeah
who's playing chess
i'll go next one
i'll go next um
def loop can't wait to catch you in game
pass
i really loved it takes two and it came
to game pass
yeah psychonauts 2 game pass ah
delicious
are you saying something there i'm
saying i'm saying we eating good over
here baby
[Laughter]
resident evil see you in gay pass
delicious i can't rejoice
down to the two people that won't be in
game pass
dread bushes i don't even know how you
made it i don't know how you made it
yeah i was actually like just just your
curiosity snow bike isn't it weird that
metro dredd had like two nominations but
it got nominated for game of the year
like i feel like that's weird yeah
yeah i don't know
it's an odd one is it just a nintendo
thing you know people dying for a
nintendo name to be out there maybe it
is the franchise right i tell king all
the time never played any of these games
i don't know the weight of them right
but it seems like everybody always
chirps about metroid how much they love
this franchise maybe that's it i don't
know mike little known fact is the uh is
the worst selling franchise in on
nintendo's uh history don't you know
good job
known fact
hey
what is it well i i have to go with uh
uh uh
give these dudes something for the year
uh because they need to puff their
chests out it's been a very bad year
they got they end in the year on
absolutely nothing so let's give them an
award that they can't physically hold
uh game of the year goes to
ratcheting
[Music]
you know what i'm gonna put my flag down
i want it takes two to win this i feel
like out of all the games here it takes
periods
but i got i got it back
definitely
oh i thought you was about to see gotta
back definitely
i got to
back it up song
it's death loop it's it's definitely
listen
like you said [ __ ] i think this is the
this is the time for arcane to shine and
hardcore arcane heads may have some
issues with how because i there are some
issues with you know the fact that it's
not quite an immersive sim cause it
holds your hand a little bit
but i think that's what they needed just
to get the article to get them yeah just
think how many
just think how many awards that death
loop and ratchet and clank's been in
like they've been in a lot
so almost every award yeah they've been
in a lot yeah it's definitely definitely
for me yeah this one is tough
because i want to go with my heart
and let's get the eliminators out sorry
resident evil i just i don't have you
here
metroid switch gang i love you but i
don't have you here
it takes two i love you
but i just can't see you winning game of
the year oh it still had there was a lot
of issues with the the the book
character
yeah people weren't happy with that oh
yeah oh yeah the book character
yeah
[Laughter]
but then it comes down to
for me my you know i know
sony nation don't get mad but like
ratchet i can't
because didn't you just say sony nation
don't get mad don't get bad so they
because i know they want it i know they
listen i know this is where they usually
clean up and they do they go they always
have high quality games
but
the world on the street cycle dance2 is
better and
and
the paperwork yeah and the story is
better and it's just the the mental
health issue stuff and there's no
disrespect to it's just more of the same
for ratchet clank to me so it came down
to me to psychonauts 2
and deflute
and my heart wants to give it to psycho
tattoo my heart was to say tim against
the w here
but that flute man
it's like sauv said i just think arcane
is under the radar to the masses
and they've never played that style of a
game
and i feel because even though again
maddie i love you he's a hardcore arcade
he feels it's not the the best that the
studio's done but i feel as a result of
their accessibility and the bringing the
other person in and stuff like that it
made it more popular so i'm going to go
with def loop i'm going to go with them
this hurts though because i wanted to go
with psychonauts too but
that's my vote man that's my vote cry yo
lord we see what's in december we'll
find out who the winners are number
ninth the day after halo comes out yeah
yeah this is a tough one let me know
lord's got it right who got it right
come back but again tremendous show
shout out to sloback bike man rocking
with us the internet thank you
oh thanks guys for having me on it was a
blast it was what a great four hours
it's been kicking it with the very best
y'all it's been awesome
he was like you got me it's all good you
know salute to you brother you know
we'll read the super chats after but we
got to give you outros first
um brother you know tremendous journey
tremendous history i love us coming
together as gamers you know what i'm
saying and just really your history is
inspiring your energy your positive
energy and all the talent talented
things you do in the gaming community
just truly amazing man we want to give
you your flowers where can the fine
people find you what else do you got
going on lord snowbite
thank you so much cog and thank you to
you and the whole entire realm everybody
here on the panel everybody out there in
the chat that has just been rocking with
us all morning and afternoon long truly
and honestly it's a blast being here and
you guys are everything that gaming
means to me positivity inclusivity fun
and just a good time of sharing
enthusiasm no matter what games you like
you all come together and laugh and have
fun and that's what i've always been
about of course you can go find me over
at kind of funny i host all of the
twitch live streams after confronting
games daily each and every weekday i
host the kind of funny xcast along with
my two gaming dads paris lily and gary
whittaker the rogue one we talk all
things xbox we're just like these guys
we love sharing the fun we keep it very
positive and uh we have a great time so
you can always check me out over there
and of course on my live channel
twitch.tv snowbike mike i stream to one
of the best communities around because
we just like playing games and having
fun so you can always check us out and
i'll be hosting more halo tournaments so
if you in the realm think you got it and
you want to bring it grab yourself a
foursome and come join our next one
they're always free to enter it's just
us having fun and uh you can enjoy that
but that's you guys snow bike mike here
in beautiful lake tahoe playing a bunch
of video games and spreading the love my
man man long overdue so happy to have
you in there attic i don't know if he's
still here if you had to run yet
yeah give your outros to mike and then i
know you could bounce out while we do
the rest of the videos
i've always liked you know i've stayed
multiple times i i value passion over
everything
and you've always shown that passion you
know like exactly like you show
like
like the negativity passion i have
that's your positive passion
like i can't match it so i gotta go the
other way i gotta be on the dark side of
the voice
[Laughter]
but i definitely appreciate you coming
on that it was it was a it was a blast
uh you know my might stream some games
with you in the future
i know you like fall guys and i really
enjoy that game
but i don't got a group to play it with
you ain't got nothing anytime man
anytime addict yeah i hope that me and
all of you right here can squad up with
some halo as well that's an easy win
right there sure gamertag's got to get
exchanged a lot of stuff got to go down
and then in person as well once things
get back to normal next year no doubt
lord solve outros for the legendary snow
bike bike
yeah mike i mean
when i first saw you i'm kind of funny
i was like i was like i like this guy
he's he's super super positive like
almost what i've told you in the past i
said in the past my wife calls it like
strawberry like yeah oh he's very
strawberry
he's super nice and whatever and i was i
was a little worried because i'm like
man
he's on this big platform sometimes the
toxicity of just the community
unfortunately can just be overwhelming
to somebody who who just wants to put
out that positive vibe because we felt
it with us here right when you know cog
is pushing positivity we're all sort of
in that boat and sometimes you get
people that just want to bring you down
and they just
they just want
to sort of engulf you in the negativity
that can happen around gaming
and i just i love to see the fact that
you just you've overcome any of that if
there was any of that that type of
hurdle that you that that you may have
experienced but you've just won everyone
over with positivity and at the end of
the day the the fact that more people
would just get on board with the idea of
hey
i'm however old i am like i'll be 46 in
two months
i'm sitting on a sunday plane talking
about video games
my childhood friends go
we have to be grateful for the things
that we're able to do and follow our
passion so uh to hear your story today
about how you know you're just this
go-getter and you're not afraid and even
if you are afraid you just do it um i
think it's a lesson for anybody who
wants to
to do anything in life like hey don't be
afraid just do it what's the worst that
can happen they can tell you no um
and the fact that you've gotten to where
you've gotten and you continue to grow
in that space is amazing man so thank
you for joining us appreciate you
thanks soph i want to take a moment that
means a lot coming from you and i want
you know for our first interaction you
have been incredible i've learned a lot
i really love your calm and even
demeanor you're so smart and fun and
insightful and a lot of the hoops fans
out there will get it if you listen to
my guys jalen and jacob but you remind
me of jacoby with these two these
knuckleheads actually called the three
of these guys
and i want you to know that it means the
world so thank you thank you brother i
appreciate it mike now we're going to
have to grease his ears when he walks
through the door because he's going to
be too big you know
i know you'll always keep in balance
let's give snow bikers flowers man i
gotta snow mike the new name of the the
can do man because kent is not in his
repertoire
the cant is not there um yo you have
this like halo over your head right here
[Music]
yeah every time i look at it i laugh so
yeah
you got that glow behind me that's
that's exactly you right
and then and i'm
i was listening to your history and
stuff like that and that and it is my um
my weird ability to just dissect little
things but your responsibility was
taught to you very early you and your
mother was on a cold frigid line for you
to go get yourself
and
she was like yeah go ahead go to school
i'm gonna hold you down
i'ma hold you down i'm gonna get that
he's like your mom please don't i got
you go to school and this is where you
learned your responsibility and what
comes first and what was what was what
mattered right she's like i'm gonna have
your fun i got your fun here don't worry
but you go take care of what matters
right and you came back and she had you
and then when you're doing your first
twitch
your mom's senior girlfriend was in the
chat
right she had you she held you she held
you down and that level of
responsibility has been with you this
whole time and that can do attitude has
always been there when i came in today
and i was telling my girl last night i'm
like man babe i don't know what song i'm
coming in with
but she was like yo she come in with
hate me now yeah right
and listen
i always love that gym song that you
listen to right because that's just what
i'm working out right
i was like nah
i said
and i look at your stuff because
sovereign is the catalyst for you guys
yeah if i would not know about god
without him yeah bro if it wasn't for
saul putting us on that's how i found
out about colin he introduced me
yeah it was solved was always and then
also kabatsu you know what i'm saying so
it's like i didn't get a chance to talk
to kai botsu about that i got a chance
to suck facts he introduced me to you
when i listened
to bob molly
last night i saw man this is mike
[Laughter]
so i came in and i was so happy that she
was into the tune and you are so ready
to go
and i thought we had you for limited
time you rocked and now sorry i'm
stretching the timeout but i want to say
these things if i don't ever get a
chance to say them again
i truly appreciate your time here i
truly appreciate your aesthetics in the
back i truly appreciate your energy so
thank you so much for coming on and
staying the whole time on the crown of
your lords this is incredible
bro
thanks king and you know for you king
cog will tell you the first time i met
cog i looked right at him with a big
smile and said you get me and king in
the room oh he's not gonna have a great
time i can't wait to be next to this guy
and king to start off i appreciate you
playing bob at the beginning and just
lightening in the mood and having fun
that's something my dad always did when
we woke up before middle school in high
school he had the record playered on the
old school mj the bg's
everybody right we would jam before we
went to school and that was something
special and for you to set the tone like
that is awesome right because i know as
you guys know when you come in to a new
spot it's quiet it's anxious people
don't know what to say they don't know
how to break the ice and you made it fun
you made it exciting so thank you king
and i love
everything you do i love your energy i
love the fun jabs because you keep it
fun you keep it positive and that's what
i need i need some good laughter in my
life so thank you big dog you know that
salute bro again the legend he has
spoken man long overdue glad we could do
it absolute pleasure so we do got to
take care of business mike i know if you
got to go it's cool because we got to
read a ton of super chats
at this point i can i feel guilty so i
was like brother
you got to go like we got business
all right well i'll run out of your way
so you guys can do that addict king sav
and cog thank you all so much in the
realm thank you for putting up with the
fun thanks for getting loud with me in
the gang it was really an awesome
opportunity and i can't wait to collide
with these guys again and of course
bring them over to my world so i will
see you all soon keep playing games be
good to one another peace out everybody
so much brother thank you brother have a
go see y'all no doubt no doubt
all right so i could do the poll while
you get things ready
yeah definitely all right um with the
recent success of halo infinite's
multiplayer beta gameplay and engagement
which core problem do you think 343
needs to address first the choices are a
progression system doesn't reward
objective play and killstreaks enough
b not enough uh free-to-play quality
content that shouldn't be time gated
c dedicated playlists like slayer or
optional unranked cross play or d
i don't care i'm spending my whole check
for them pvp suits i can't be an ashy
spartan out here shout out to the realm
it is up for ilv
check download the gamer.net check that
out when you can and uh yeah so okay
spartans man
did you see his legs
hustle and motivate two dollars shout
out to mike at the nba streets volume
two love yes classic
okay i love bbc
parenthesis big black consoles oh yeah
yeah
come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
with the 10 super chat please change the
name of the podcast the king and the
iron lords
uh the legend of crystal d it would be a
good man oh sweat come on man this guy
here buddy
man
we
[Music]
i hope they add modes mode selection and
turn off cross play battle class doesn't
bother me spend money if you want to
hashtag ashy spartan
no kd spartans no
then we got the homie stitch
remember for 25 months thank you sir
much appreciated i have completed every
challenge the events and tanked and
tanked platinum 4 and just getting 50 xp
also there's another game mode called
survivor there's an achievement that you
asked to revive a fallen team that you
asked to revive a fallen teammate so
there's a yeah there's a number of
different things you can do um we have
don otaku five dollar super chat
go to level 30 got to level 38 all natty
with no skips and completed my weekly
challenges
okay two days i don't like it
so he had no progression basically for
two days that's crazy yeah
sucks do the challenges
you will grow
then we have paws
in all seriousness people are spending
money in halo multiplayer because they
love the game
awesome job 343 for letting anyone play
while allowing us to buy if we have the
money hashtag halo is back
then we have tyson
joe 15 super chat the main problem with
infinite is content we don't have forge
custom games are more limited compared
to older halos and missing game modes
slash playlists possibly no new maps
till next season in six months
that's the thing though right like okay
if they launch with those 10 maps like
you see how the expectations change yeah
if they launch regular halo with those
10 maps they're good now they're like oh
we're not getting new maps in six months
it's like wait a minute hold up yeah
it's halo you're talking about right
all right cheney once again 10 super
chat so has halo just beat all sony ps5
games combined for
sales
revenue
each halo edition console sold includes
a copy of campaign and ad battle pass
spending hashtag halo is king and it
eats like one two
then we have tyson bjo once again eight
dollars on chat we've been conditioned
to fill up an xp bar since cod 2007.
definitely want a performance xp system
still the funnest game i've played in a
long time it's true
humans like to see the numbers go up
then we'll uh we have dan lazaro five
thousand chat this is why we single
player only mode players don't care
about other moments
a whole lot of complaining not a lot of
gaming y'all never see it coming
[Laughter]
strong words for the multiplayer game
there you go hargie cheney just to get
yet again five dollars of a [ __ ] now that
we know co-op will be coming soon when
do you think it drops my guess it'll be
announced at e3 could come in june or
next fall oh my
drop on the rising head
good afternoon realm i hope everyone had
a great week like little man did this
black friday yes killed it
pick up a tlc television and grab little
man out the door
i'm very excited for something very soon
wink wink
lame
little insider yeah yeah he got i know
that's that lord gave me that dead eggs
you know what time it is no doubt
then we have necromancer zale
with the five dollars of a chat did
anyone else see the halo edition series
x and halo elite controller available on
the microsoft store yesterday yes sir i
didn't know it was available
they drop them every other day shout out
to a lot of people that have been
telling me
check the store every other hour
so and also check your emails because
they're sending emails yeah to specific
yeah direct links for value customers so
that they'll avoid the scalpers they're
like yo you've evaluated we know that
you don't got it we're gonna send you a
link you click this so so far so far
only no but they they send them to
owners already as well because i so what
they'll do though it's a package you're
not you're not buying just the comments
yeah you gotta buy a little bit more
but you know hey uh let me see gaming
forte five dollars will be chat in my
rose dawson titanic voice
it's been 10 years since my wolverines
bested those hated ohio state buckeyes
hail to the victors hail to michigan i
don't know if that's how rose talks but
i'm sure she didn't talk like a
45 year old man
then we got marvin ginyard five dollars
a chat bought a little man for the
office to compliment the big man into
the entertainment room game changer
little man again another little man
shout out
then we got shroom kingdom 2 chat bring
return on the pc and i'll let you know
oh
and response to somebody to somebody
here
then we got lord metroid two dollar
super chat king
got your hello kitty knee pads because
metroid is game of the year
i hope you stand on that square yeah
and see you right after the show
i love metroid that ain't happening
that'd be funny that would be funny the
wildest thing is no we already seen it
there we got hard geek chinese
mike next time bring either greg or gary
wow wow
shout out to greg shout out to gary let
me see did we get any more at the end of
this
uh we got the rubber now
just bought my new c1 bring on the 120
fps gonna put the work to my series x
that's right not your playstation five
and we got derek summer five dollars a
chat i gave halo infinite a hundred
dollars after visiting master chief
collection for the first time this week
as a 31 year old gamer master chief
collection with straight nostalgia 343
can also fix infinite that's for sure
it's like you said there's nothing wrong
with the game it's just that yes
that's it we're caught up all caught up
no doubt you already know what it is
time to go i do gotta read just a couple
of sh
merch that then it came in and then we
we got oh yeah shout out to the whole oh
wow shout out okay shout out to the
homie i gotta put the put the launcher
gamer.net up right now for my boy mach
mood he got the stainless water bottle
he said what started out is randomly
applying to write for lognet two years
ago spanned into true friendship and
camaraderie here's to 10k
and here's to the road to 50k and future
lords of gaming.net growth your brother
from bahrain mock mode
love him max such a good dude yo please
do me a favor y'all i don't ask for much
besides click the like button and
retweet we know that go to lords of
gaming.net and do me a favor and go to
the must read section there's a little
arrow there just hit that arrow just
read those articles those are from
editorial those are some of our best
work
please catch my brother macmoon he's got
a great article about how gaming is in
the middle east how to pick up systems i
mean we we international y'all we got a
full
squad canada's in the building nicholas
downey we we everywhere man so yo please
support lawsuit gave me that i had to
shout my brother back more one more
mercy got um
you also got the 10k classic you got the
black shirt you know what i'm saying and
this is
limited edition those are going away yes
those are going away um also that that
sale is going away so get that 50 off
because today's the last day for that um
necromancer zale bought a classic t
great show guys king is hilarious today
all hailed the king he bought they throw
him in the bushes t
salute you know what said that girl man
that's a no doubt so the merchants
caught up and i think another super chat
wrote and then we could get it yeah we
got derek summer five dollars in chat
while i wait for 343 to fix infinite
progression i have their final campaign
to complete on legendary thoughts on
destiny's new hard mode campaign
yeah we got to get into it i mean it's
it's a good idea i agree with you um
some people want to wait i just can't
wait the game's too fun but i understand
you know and destiny's horrible campaign
i think that needs to happen long since
yesterday because they got some good
content but that's what i got addicts
out of here right he did what he got to
do he's going yep i think he had to
leave he had to bounce out sorry
we got to do it
fool's been done king look tremendous
thing thank you all for rocking with us
tremendous we got more stuff planned for
the end of the year enjoy your holiday
we up out of here unless anybody got
anything else nope
45 dollars
everybody we out peace i'm so mad at
halo
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughs